...
Ich mute mich da auch mal.
Hörst du mich noch?
Bist du im WLAN oder bist du im LAN?
Ich bin im WLAN
tatsächlich.
Das lässt sich aber beheben. Sekunde.
Ansonsten läuft die Aufnahme
schon ganz gut.
Jetzt kann ich glaube ich
Edit Marken.
Edit Marken. Warum setze ich
die nicht da?
Achso, weil ich da diese Mitlauftaste
oder sowas.
Ah, jetzt werden sie an der richtigen Stelle gesetzt.
Das kann ich sogar wieder löschen.
Cool.
Und was brauche ich noch?
Das ist jetzt die Aufnahme.
Okay, Ethernet-Adapter.
So, jetzt bist du weg.
Hallo?
Ja, hey, Kilian.
Hey Henrik.
Grüß dich.
Ja, nehmen wir wieder eine Folge auf hier.
Ja, das ist akronomisierbar, Folge 44.
Jetzt haben wir ja schon eine Weile lang nicht gequatscht.
Hauptsächlich auch, weil irgendwie Pandemie halt und alles ist doof.
Klingt scheiße.
Ich habe aber auch irgendwie, irgendwie haben wir festgestellt,
jetzt auch so an die Zuhörer, Kean und ich,
wir haben uns halt auch lange Zeit einfach auch nicht unterhalten,
ohne nicht gleichzeitig einen Podcast aufzunehmen dabei.
Deswegen haben wir auch gesagt, naja, lass uns das erstmal hier wieder ein bisschen ruhig angehen.
Und deswegen haben wir auch ein paar Mal einfach keine Folge aufgenommen
und haben uns einfach mal so zum Labern getroffen.
Es war auch mal wieder Zeit irgendwie, dass die Sachen zu Kurs kommen.
Fühlt man sich so beobachtet.
Dieser Podcast ist ja quasi entstanden als Idee.
Einfach, wenn wir drüber labern, das können wir doch auch aufnehmen und ins Netz schieben.
Ja, genau.
Also ich meine, als wir uns das letzte Mal unterhalten haben,
da ein bisschen in der Stadt spazieren gegangen sind, da sind auch Kunde.
Aber ich meine, man muss ja nicht alles aufzeichnen.
Okay, Alexa.
Ich habe neulich,
nachdem wir uns unterhalten hatten,
dass ich gefragt habe,
ob dieser neue Apple HomePod,
ob der Spotify unterstützt.
Weil ich überlegt habe, hole ich mir so ein Ding,
da ist vielleicht das mit der Überwachung
nicht ganz so schlimm,
wenn du dir ein Apple-Produkt holst.
Anstatt zu meinem Echo, was ich zu Hause habe.
Aber ich möchte ja trotzdem sagen können,
einfach bloß Siri spielt dieses Lied
und dann spielt das einfach sofort über Spotify.
Bei dem Amazon Echo kannst du einstellen,
was der Hauptmusikservice ist.
Da kannst du halt von Amazon Music zu Spotify wechseln.
Und dann spielt das halt sofort,
wenn du einfach nach irgendeinem Lied fragst,
das von Spotify ab.
Und das wäre so ein Feature, was mir wichtig wäre,
wenn ich zu so einem HomePod wechseln würde,
damit ich nicht meine ganzen,
man baut ja auch mein Profil auf,
wenn man da ist,
fängst du wieder bei Null an.
Das wäre so meine einzige Überlegung.
Das setzt voraus,
dass du bei Apple Music ein Profil aufbauen kannst,
aber ich glaube, so klug ist Apple Music da leider gar nicht.
Nee, also ich meine,
Spotify kannst ja wirklich auch mal sagen,
jetzt spiel doch mal irgendwie Daily Mix Nummer 5
und dann ist es irgendwas,
was grob deinem Musikgeschmack entspricht
und ähnlich ist zu Sachen, die du
entweder Sachen, die du schon kennst oder Sachen, die
in die Richtung fallen. Das fand ich eigentlich bei Spotify
ein schönes Video. Aber ich will ja auch keine Spotify-Werbung machen.
Zumindest habe ich mir dann
nach Referenzen geguckt, ob man das
irgendwie einstellen kann, weil du dir ja auch nicht sicher bist,
weil du kein Spotify benutzt.
Dass man kann es nutzen.
Ja, aber nicht so, wie du meinst.
Du kannst es irgendwie als, du kannst diesen
HomePod als Senker einstellen und dann kannst
dann auch irgendwie auf dem Gerät,
auf deinem Handy kannst du
Spotify anmachen und dann gibt es irgendwie
Send to HomePod.
Dann ist es aber, glaube ich,
entweder ist es AirPlay
oder du hast das halt wirklich so als Senker eingestellt.
Und das ist als...
Das ist AirPlay.
Nee, es ist AirPlay.
Es gibt ja diesen Spotify-Dienst,
dass du sagst, dieses Gerät ist mit meinem Account
assoziiertes Spotify-Abspielgerät.
Was du ja auch mit dem Solar-Playern machen kannst.
Aber du kannst dem Ding nicht sagen,
Siri, spiel dieses Lied.
Da kannst du das.
Aber das spielt halt überhaupt die Musik.
Ja, das ist halt doof.
Aber ich hatte mir so ein Video angeguckt und der Typ, der das vorgestellt hatte, das ein bisschen demonstriert hatte, was da die Einschränkungen sind, der hatte jedes Mal, wenn er Hey Siri gesagt hat, hat er das gebliebt, als wäre es ein Schimpfwort. Das fand ich sehr lustig, so nach dem Motto, das hat halt Seiteneffekte, wenn ich das sage in diesem Video für andere Leute, die sich das gerade angucken.
Ja klar, viele Podcasts machen das auch immer und setzen das so was wie Hey Dingus oder Hey Assistant, damit man da nicht auswärts den Geräten bei Leuten triggert.
Aber es ist doch total scheiße, oder?
Ja, sehr.
Es gibt zum Beispiel diesen wunderbaren
Hoaxilla-Podcast,
wo sie sich so Urban Legends
vornehmen und die analysieren
und erst erzählen. Das ist auch ein bisschen gruselig
und dann auflösen, warum das Quatsch ist.
Zumindest bei diesem Podcast
sind die Moderatoren
ein Ehepaar aus Hamburg und das sind
Alex und Alexa.
Ah, verstehe.
Und da ist es teilweise auch so, dass dann,
wenn ein Mann Gast dabei ist und die sich gegenseitig
begrüßen und ansprechen, dann macht er erstmal
Oh, warte mal einen Moment, ich muss mal kurz
mein Echo ausmachen.
Das ist doch scheiße, wenn man für all die Frauen, die Alexa
heißen, dass die jetzt so einen
dass das der Name jetzt
irgendwie so ein Trigger-Word ist.
Das geht auch nicht mehr weg. Das hat dir wirklich
sicherlich, wenn auch nicht viel, aber ein bisschen
Lebensqualität genommen.
Auf jeden Fall. Gut, okay.
Aber wo wir gerade bei
Sicherheits- oder Überwachung
und Apple reden,
Was haben wir denn heute so für Themen klären?
Das ist die Frage,
welches Thema aus der Themenliste
du damit anschickern möchtest.
Es gibt da zwei, die da recht gut matchen.
Aber ich glaube, die sprechen
wir eh beide an, da können wir auch einfach oben anfangen.
Wahrscheinlich
meinst du mit Sicherheit, obwohl,
ja, gehen wir mal zu dem Fuck-Up der Woche, genau.
Ist doch sehr gut.
Oh, ein NPM-Fuck-Up der Woche?
Nein, diesmal ein Apple-Fuck-Up.
Nein!
Wurde sich explizit im Matrix gewöhnt,
dass wir das Thema mal ansprechen.
Und zwar hat Apple ja Big Sur
gelauncht, das neueste
Next Major OS Update für den Mac.
Mac OS XI.
Quasi.
Naja.
Die Bezeichnung haben sich ja jetzt fallen lassen.
Das ist ja einfach nur noch Mac OS 11, beziehungsweise
10.16 kannst du im Code auch abfragen,
je nachdem, wie du es machen möchtest. Hat wohl ein kleiner
andere unterschiedliche semantische Bedeutung,
aber die habe ich wieder vergessen. Also irgendwie
gab es da einen Unterschied. Ich glaube, das war die Frage,
ob du auf einem armen Mac bist oder nicht.
aber weiß ich gerade nicht mehr.
Achso, 11 heißt das nur, wenn du so einen
neuen Apple-Silicon-Computer hast?
Wie gesagt, ich weiß
nicht mehr, wo der genau Unterschied lag. Ich glaube, du kannst
den Check nach 11 und 10.16 auf beiden
Plattformen, auf Intel machen
und auf den neuen Chips
oder auf dem DTK damals zumindest,
auf dem Developer-Tech-Preview-Ding
konntest du nur den 10.11.
nur den 11. Check machen.
Wie gesagt, ich weiß es nicht mehr. Vielleicht ist es auch
Bullshit, aber es gab auf jeden Fall irgendeinen witzigen
Unterschied. Kurzer Tangent, das ist ja so
so ein allgemeines Problem, wenn du ein Produkt hast,
mit dem andere Leute interagieren,
wo du die Versionsnummer
lange Zeit nicht änderst und dann plötzlich
änderst du die Versionsnummer. Ich weiß, dass die Diskussion
beim Linux-Körnel
irgendwie war, jetzt sind wir,
die haben irgendwie fünf Jahre lang
2.26 und dann irgendwie eine
dreistellige dritte Stelle gehabt
und irgendwann kam halt
der Linux-3-Körnel raus,
weil irgendwie
Linus Torwald irgendwie mal
mit dem linken Fuß aus dem Bett aufgestanden ist oder so.
Und da sind so viele Bildskripte
kaputt gegangen oder irgendwelche Sachen, die
explizit nach einem 226er oder so
Colonel gefragt haben.
Das ist doch total bescheuert. Ich meine,
man weiß doch, dass das irgendwo mal hochgehen
wird.
Es kann sein, dass es ewig,
dass diese 226er-Version,
zumindest ist das auch ewig passiert. Ich kann mir vorstellen,
dass es jetzt auch einige Sachen gab, die
gecheckt haben, auf was für einem System laufe ich
und dann irgendwie nicht damit klarkam,
dass da plötzlich eine 11 vorne steht und bloß
so Year-2-K-Bug-mäßig
alles ab der zweiten Stelle
gelesen haben. Vorne steht immer
die 10. Wo sind wir jetzt? Sind wir jetzt bei 17 oder
18?
Nee, wir sind bei 0, 1. Na, das muss
falsch sein. Das war dieser Windows-9
Dings-Thema auch damals, oder?
Dass die Windows-9 übersprungen haben,
um Leuten vorzubeugen,
die den Check-Off fängt
der 9 an. Oh, 95, 98,
ganz alt. Genau.
Aber ja, bei sowas verstehe ich es ja noch
ein bisschen mehr, wo das halt wirklich schon sehr lange
im Wachsen ist und da
wirklich Legacy-Software unterwegs ist
und was weiß ich was, da ist es ja
doof, aber ich verstehe es,
aber wenn du schon so eine
ansatzweise semantische
Versionsnummer wie der Linux-Körnel hast und dann
du was nicht checkst, das ist ja schon dumm.
Naja, würde mir auch passieren.
Gehe ich fest von aus. Anyway, Tangent
beendet, wir wollten eigentlich über was anderes reden.
Genau, die haben das Big Sur
Update rausgehauen
und Apple hatte schon vor kurzem
schon vor Big Sur, so ein Feature in macOS drin,
dass hin und wieder bei dem Start einer Applikation
dein Mac bei Apple-Servern nachschaut,
ob diese Applikation von einem Developer-Zertifikat
gesignt wurde, welches mittlerweile revoked wurde.
Und dieser Check gegen Apple-Server,
der hat den Apple so implementiert,
dass wenn dein Mac offline ist,
beziehungsweise kein Internet hat,
dann fehlt es einfach, also ein Soft-Fail,
und öffnet die App trotzdem,
damit du einfach keine Probleme hast,
was auch sehr sinnvoll ist, logischerweise,
weil man will ja nicht, dass man nur online auf dem Mac
Programme eröffnen kann. Was Apple
allerdings nicht beachtet hat, ist wie
dieses Tool damit umgeht, wenn
dein Rechner online ist, aber
Apples Server nicht antworten, beziehungsweise
wenn die sehr, sehr langsam antworten.
Und das ist eben eingetreten, dadurch, dass
sehr viele auf Mac OS Big Sur geupdatet haben und
irgendwie von Trust D, diesem D-Mount,
der da läuft, witzigerweise Trust D heißt,
diese Checks gestartet
wurden und diese Server sind wohl abgeschmiert, beziehungsweise
haben sehr, sehr, sehr langsam geantwortet
und Trust D
dann auf voller CPU-Euerlast diesen Check versucht,
eine Antwort zu bekommen und hat einfach die App sich geöffnet.
Was ein lächerlicher Weg ist, wie das gefällt ist.
Gut, das ist hoffentlich auf die Art und Weise jetzt gefixt,
beziehungsweise mit dem nächsten Update irgendwann,
dass das nicht wieder passiert.
Aber das größere Problem an der Sache war ja,
dass Leute darauf aufmerksam geworden sind,
was TrustD da macht und dass TrustD quasi checkt,
ob diese App laufen darf von der Idee her.
Und dass das ganz schnell die Runde gemacht hat,
hey, da geht es um ein Request an ocsp.apple.com.
Wenn die einfach wegblockt, dann läuft das wieder super.
Und auf der anderen Seite, warte mal, Apple schaut nach.
Apple kriegt quasi eine Liste von allen Apps, die ich starte.
Das ist aber nicht so geil.
Das war dieser Your Mac is not your own Blogpost.
Ich glaube schon, genau.
Der von Jeff Johnson,
der auch die herrliche Safari-Erweiterung Stop the Madness baut,
beziehungsweise auch andere Browser supportet.
supported, der hatte da auch noch was geschrieben.
Das habe ich auch in den Journals schon verlinkt.
Aber dieses Your Computer is not your own, der steht noch nicht in den Journals.
Pack mal auch mit rein.
Genau.
Also ist ja an sich was dran.
Du schickst ja quasi irgendeinen Hash oder irgendeinen Wert
an Apple, wo das eben nachgeprüft wird.
Und das Problem an OCSP ist halt auch,
dass das halt unverschlüsselt ist. Sprich, jeder kann
das mitlesen. Das hat halt den
Grund, dass
so ein altes Protokoll, wo versteht
das nochmal, für Online Certificate
Status Protocol OCSP?
Also aus der Ära, als jeder für jeden Scheiß ein komplett neues Protokoll erfunden hat,
das einfach nur ein REST-Request für irgendwas ist.
Heute ist alles HTTP schon ein bisschen lame eigentlich.
Ja, aber es wäre wenigstens verschlüsselt.
Ja, aber das Problem an sowas ist halt, also explizit an diesem Protokoll ist,
dass du nachschauen willst, gerade auch für TLS-Zertifikate,
ob die revoked worden sind.
Und es wäre halt irgendwie ein bisschen dumm, wenn du den Request machen willst,
ob dein Zertifikat revoked wurde.
Und dann musst du plötzlich einen TLS-Handcheck machen.
Oh, warte mal, muss ich mal schauen, ob das revoked wurde.
und dann nochmal.
Moment, das Check.
Ja, ja, ja.
Die Idee dahinter ist halt, es explizit nicht verschlüsselt zu machen,
damit du nicht in so einen Loop reinrennst.
Das ist aber...
Das ist die Idee hinter OCSP.
Das muss man hier nicht machen.
Das ist hier absolut irrsinnig.
Trusky könnte auch TLS sprechen, absolut.
Weil jetzt könnte, jetzt fällt mir jetzt nichts ein,
man könnte diesen Service, diesen, wie heißt das, OCSP?
Ja.
Den könnte man auch man in the middle,
wenn er nicht verschlüsselt ist.
Das heißt, ich stelle einfach irgendwas bei dir ins Netzwerk,
Was einfach bei all deinen Programmen,
die du, bei all diesen Anfragen,
die du mit deinem Mac machst,
zurückgibt, nö, das Zertifikat ist revoked.
Und dann geht bei dir kein Programm mehr auf.
Ja, aber viel schlimmer doch in die andere Richtung.
Du installierst bei mir Malware
und schaust, wenn diese Malware-Checks
gemacht werden an Apple, dann lässt du,
wird aber hier der Check von irgendwas anderem weitergeleitet.
Und da geht's dann ja. Aber ich glaube,
Trusty ist nicht ganz blöde und macht da,
das ist ja auch ein signierter Wert,
der zurückkommt, beziehungsweise dahin geschickt wird.
Also ich meine, das mitigated das schon irgendwo mit, aber da bin ich mir jetzt nicht sicher.
Stimmt, keine Verschlüsselung heißt nicht, keine Signatur. Das stimmt.
Genau, aber theoretisch könnte ja zumindest jeder mitlesen, was du da hinschickst.
Und die Grundidee, die da rumging, war das aber ziemlich blöde, weil da kann jeder mitlesen, wann ich welche App öffne.
Und das ist nicht so geil.
Was da aber ein bisschen später noch ein schöner Blogpost rauskam, ist, dass das nicht ganz so wahr ist.
Also gerade zwei Sachen machen das ein bisschen zunichte.
Zum einen wird das natürlich nicht bei jedem Start von der App ausgemacht,
sondern nur, wenn ein Trustee meint, das zu machen.
Das wird ziemlich lang gecashed.
Sprich, mit dem Big Sur Update beim OS Update
haben es wahrscheinlich relativ viele gemacht.
Und da ist dann was Blödes passiert.
Aber das muss doch bei jedem Mac OS Update passiert sein.
Ja, wer weiß.
Vielleicht haben die da irgendwie nur einen Server laufen gehabt zu der Zeit,
weil jemand nicht aufgepasst hat.
Apple macht ja leider kein öffentliches...
Wie heißt das im Nachhinein, wenn man da noch mal drauf schaut,
was da schiefgelaufen ist.
Genau, Apple macht ja kein öffentliches Postmortem
an der Stelle. Du weißt ja nicht, was da jetzt
letztendlich passiert ist. Vielleicht war da irgendein anderer
Fuck-up. Oder Trusty macht das
normalerweise nicht bei einem OS-Update.
Oder Big Sur hat das irgendwie anders getriggert
und hat das plötzlich für alles andere gemacht.
Weiß ich nicht. Keine Ahnung.
Auf jeden Fall macht Trusty das halt nicht bei jedem
Start, sondern nur hin und wieder.
Relativ selten sogar. Und
was auch noch dazu kommt,
ist, dass Trusty nicht das für jede
spezifische App macht, sondern für Developer-Zertifikationen.
Karte. Sprich, wenn mehrere
Apps von einem Developer Certificate kommen,
wie zum Beispiel, das war in dem Post das Beispiel, Firefox
und Thunderbird, auch wenn Thunderbird tot ist, aber nur
als Beispiel, nutzen ja trotzdem
noch Leute. Thunderbird wird jetzt von
irgendjemand anders weiterentwickelt, habe ich auch mal mit verpasst.
Oh, oh, oh. Na, damit wir
nicht mal drüber reden.
Nee, aber zum Beispiel, die beiden Apps, die werden mit demselben
Zertifikat gesigned und dann würdest du nicht
den Unterschied im Request sehen können, welche App das wäre.
Das ist natürlich trotzdem blöd, dass man sieht, dass eine Mozilla
App gestartet wurde, aber es würde zumindest,
Also es ist nicht ganz so schlimm, wie man denken würde.
Vor allem, weil der Check nicht jedes Mal kommt.
Und das macht halt schon einen Riesenunterschied aus.
An sich ist es aber ein relativ cleveres System.
Apple nutzt es auch schon eine Weile.
Und man gibt lange schon dieses Vorurteil,
dass Apple-Laptiker immer behaupten,
hier, macOS-Viren gibt es nicht.
Und alle Leute behaupten, ja,
aber nur weil das System so unpopulär ist.
Das ist beides irgendwo ein bisschen Bullshit.
Aber der Grund, warum sich Malware auf macOS
halt nicht so wirklich ausbreitet,
Es gibt natürlich auch die Gründe, dass es einfach nicht so populär ist,
kein so riesiges Ziel, es ist nicht ganz so einfach.
Andere Gründe, bla bla bla.
Aber Apple ist da halt auch sehr hinterher.
Und wenn sich sowas bekannt macht, dass sowas passiert,
es gibt schon definitiv Mechanismen, die in macOS eingebaut sind,
die sowas verhindern.
Und tatsächlich zum Beispiel auch sowas, wenn halt so eine irgendeine,
es gibt natürlich auch natürlich Malware, die nicht gesigned ist.
Die wird vielleicht auf die meisten Max gar nicht gestartet,
weil die meisten Leute per default diese Option gar nicht anhaben,
dass angesignte Software gestartet werden kann.
Aber zum Beispiel passieren ja auch, dass Apps gekauft werden
von irgendwelchen malicious Actoren
und dann übernommen werden, irgendwelcher Bullshit injected wird.
Und wenn sowas halt gemerkt wird,
und da ist Apple, wie gesagt, sehr hinterher davon,
dann wird das sehr, sehr schnell aus dem Verkehr genommen.
Und das läuft halt genau über sowas mit.
Und da wird das Zertifikat revoked
und dann kann diese App nicht mehr gestartet werden
auf allen Systemen.
Und das ist halt schon ein ziemlich cooles Sicherheitsfeature
auf der anderen Seite.
Also will man das eigentlich auch nicht desablen,
dass das existiert.
Das stimmt, aber Apple hat jetzt auch mir bekannt gegeben,
dass wir irgendwas ändern an dem Protokoll.
davon habe ich zumindest nichts mitbekommen,
aber wenn sie das bekannt gegeben haben,
ich würde mir zum einen wünschen, dass es vielleicht verschlüsselt ist,
einfach nur als extra Decke noch
oben drüber, zum anderen würde ich mir wünschen,
dass es natürlich das Trust-D nicht so blöde
ist und dann auf 100% CPU-Last
dahinter herrasselt,
wenn der Apple-Zäuber nicht erreichbar ist,
das ist genauso Soft-Fail, also das würde ich mir
vor allem als Update hier jetzt wünschen.
Also ich glaube, dieses
Bootstrapping-Problem, dass du dasselbe
Protokoll zum Revoken
von dem Transportzertifikat
verwendest, das lässt sich
durch Pinning oder sowas verhindern.
Ja, absolut. Vor allem nutzen die das
ja nicht für die TLS-Zertifikate hier.
Die nutzen das ja für was ganz anderes. Also hast du das Problem
ja eigentlich nicht. Genau, genau.
Also mir war als, ob ich noch in einem Blogpost
irgendwas überflogen hätte, dass
Apple jetzt Besserung gelobt
oder irgendwas. Ich dachte, du könntest das vielleicht zusammenfassen,
aber vielleicht habe ich mich auch verlesen.
Kann gut sein, aber das habe ich noch nicht auf dem
Radar gehabt, aber wäre nur erwartenswert
und hoffenswert, wenn Apple
mitkriegt, dass es so ein riesen Fuck-Up war, der durch die
Medien geht. Von wegen jeder
Mac-Nutzer war halt betroffen und konnte
den Abend lang keine Apps starten. Das ist halt bescheuert.
Das kann halt nicht sein. Also es hatte
definitiv dieses, ich will
jetzt keinen Apple-Podcast
daraus machen, dafür hast du ja noch deine andere
Plattform, aber irgendwie hat
dieses OS-Update
besonders viel Fleck bekommen.
Also von den Design-Änderungen
und Fuck-Ups mal abgesehen, das ist jetzt halt
wie Windows 8 so eher
Tablet-mäßig aussieht von der UI.
Dass es
Security-Vulnerabilities
hat, aber die, eigentlich
hatten diese Security-Vulnerabilities
auch alle anderen
macOS-Versionen vorher auch schon,
die wir jetzt besprochen haben.
Das war jetzt keine Security-Vulnerability an sich.
Das war ja, wenn dann eine Privacy-Vulnerability
und halt
eine Usability
fuck up.
Dann gab es irgendwie noch Storys, dass
ältere Geräte gebrickt wurden.
Ja, das ist schon scheiße. Ich hatte jetzt irgendwie
neulich Twitter von
einer Bekannte hier aus dem Dresden-Umfeld,
die ein Foto von ihrem
updatenden MacBook
von 2015 gemacht hat und
geschrieben hat, nach wie vielen Stunden sollte man
anfangen, sich Sorgen zu machen bei dem Update?
Den Tweet habe ich auch gelesen.
Ich habe noch nicht nachgefragt, wie lange
es dann endgültig gedauert hat, bis das Update
hat. Sie hat dann neu gestartet
nach ein paar Stunden und jetzt scheint es
wieder zu laufen.
Man fragt sich auch, nach wie vielen Stunden mache ich mal
das Reboot während der ein OS-Update installiert,
hat man natürlich auch Schiss, dass es kaputt geht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Ich wüsste bei so einem Gerät gar nicht, wie ich das,
wenn es einmal gebrickt ist, wieder zurücksetze.
So kriegt man, wahrscheinlich kriegt man
MacOS auf USB-Sticks oder sowas.
Wenn es gebrickt ist, ist das nicht die Definition des Begriffs,
dass du halt die Hardware gearscht hast
und da kannst du nichts mehr machen?
Nee, ich glaube, bei einem Update, wenn du das auch wie
Update in einem inkonsistenten Zustand abbrichst
bei einem normalen Computer,
solltest du ja trotzdem...
Ja, aber das ist ja kein Brick.
Das ist noch nicht gebrickt, nee, das stimmt.
Es gab ja damals, das erinnere ich noch mal gut dran zurück,
die PSP, diese Sony
Handheld Playstation,
die war ein herrliches Gerät,
hatte eine richtig coole Szene auch drumherum
von Leuten, die Homebrew Software dafür geschrieben haben,
das fand ich richtig großartig.
Da habe ich auch mit Ben zusammen
die erste Programmiererfahrung damals auf der Plattform
gemacht und hatten sehr viel Spaß.
Und da gab es richtig coolen Shit drauf.
Aber woran ich mich da auch noch
sehr gut dran zurückerinnere, dass die da halt so ein Ding hatten,
dass du die PSP sehr einfach bricken konntest
durch kaputte OS-Dinger, die du draufschieben willst.
Gerade wenn du das Ding jailbraken möchtest,
dann kann es natürlich passieren.
Und da gab es halt, irgendwann hatte irgendwer entdeckt,
dass in dem Akku der PSP ein 8-Bit-Speicher ist.
Ich weiß nicht, wie man drauf kommt,
aber irgendwer hat mal den Akku aufgemacht und gemerkt,
wait, was ist das da?
Und dann kam raus, wenn dieser Speicher
mit einer ganz bestimmten Folge beschrieben ist,
dann kann er eine gebrickte PSP zurücksetzen.
Und das war dann so ein riesen Breakthrough in der Szene
von wegen diesem ganzen Trash an PSPs,
die die Leute hier in der Schublade haben,
weil die Hacker hier alle ihre Dinger schrotten.
Das kannst du halt nichts machen, wenn die Dinger im Arsch sind.
Dann gab es so diesen Pandora-Akku, wurde der genannt.
Einen Akku, den du explizit damit beschrieben hast,
den hast du reingelegt und dann lief das Ding wieder.
Das war der Hammer.
Und dann gab es Leute, die haben Online-Akkus verkauft.
Also du konntest diesen Pandora-Akku nicht zum Laden benutzen,
sondern nur zum Zurücksetzen.
Und dann musst du den Speicher neu flashen.
Aber dann gab es Leute, die haben...
Die Batterie, du hast die Batterie rausgenommen?
und dann hast du eine andere Batterie reingemacht, oder was?
Genau, du hast eine Batterie reingesteckt,
die in dem Speicher eine ganz bestimmte Zahl gespeichert hatte.
Ich glaube, es waren einfach wirklich,
also ich weiß nicht mehr, was das war.
Aber dann haben Leute angefangen,
online Akkus zu verkaufen mit einem kleinen Flip-Schalter,
wo du umschalten konntest zwischen dem normalen Betrieb
und dem Pandora-Modus.
Das war schon super cool.
Sehr lustig.
Das ist auf jeden Fall nicht schön.
Das war witzig.
Ne, ja, soviel zum Apple-Fuck-Up.
Ich hoffe, das hat sich jetzt
gegessen demnächst das Thema. Ich hoffe, sie
besser dann ein bisschen nach und optimieren die Prozesse.
Und ich hoffe, so ein Shit passiert nicht
nochmal. Also ein bisschen lächerlich,
dass sowas in der Richtung passiert. Aber gut,
ist halt bisher noch nicht passiert. Und wenn die Sachen noch nicht
passiert sind, dann kann man natürlich in jegliche
Fehler mal reinrennen. Hoffentlich lernt man das halt aus.
Ich meine, das sind alles so Sachen, die
wo man sich immer
als Entwickler fragt. Daher eigentlich ein paar
von diesen Call-Home-Funktionalitäten
möchte man als Entwickler ja schon
in sein Produkt einbauen. Ich denke
so an Telemetry, in unserem
Produkt ist auch irgendwie Telemetry eingebaut,
wenn du das benutzt, dann schickt das
halt regelmäßig im Abstand
schon bestimmte Daten an uns
zurück, halt nicht mit wem du redest,
sondern so allgemein zum Thema
Audioqualität oder Netzwerkqualität
oder allgemein sowas.
Und da gelten dann eigentlich für solche
Daten die gleichen
GDPR-Regeln
wie für alles andere auch, das heißt, es darf
keine personenbezogenen Daten enthalten
und muss auf jeden Fall nach
ich lege mich drauf fest, aber ich glaube
in 90 Tagen oder so gelöscht werden
und darf halt nur für den Betrieb
deines Services genutzt werden.
Und sowas ist eigentlich in allen Sachen drin.
Selbst in Firefox ist Telemetry drin.
Ja klar.
Ist ja an sich auch nichts Verkehrtes.
Du willst ja wissen, wie Leute das Produkt nutzen,
damit du weißt, an welchen Stellen du rumdoktern musst.
Und eine Crashlog sammeln ist halt super sinnvoll.
Aber du musst halt darauf achten,
dass du es halt nicht übertreibst und anfängst,
persönliche Daten abzuschnorcheln.
Ich hätte mal mit einem Typen gesprochen,
die haben so ein SDK entwickelt für mobile,
für iOS war das explizit,
aber ich glaube auch generell für iOS und Android,
dass du deine Apps einbauen kannst
und dann hast du Crashlogs bekommen,
aber du konntest auch Screenrecording sehen und so weiter,
was die Leute wirklich mit den Geräten gemacht haben
zu dem Crashlog.
So in die Richtung, aber weirder haben die das gemacht.
Und dann haben die halt erzählt,
dass das halt, hoffentlich nutzt meine Bank das nicht,
habe ich dann zu ihm gemeint.
Ja, so klar, viele Banken nutzen das auch schon.
Wait, what?
so ein Screen Recording aus der App direkt.
Das ist halt alles andere als okay.
Das ist gar nicht geil sowas.
Immerhin zeigt die iOS mittlerweile an,
wenn deine Kamera läuft.
Aber eine App, die eine Berechtigung hat,
deine Kamera abzufragen, kann das halt auch jederzeit machen.
Die musst du dir ja nicht UI dafür anzeigen,
dass die deine Kameradaten abgreift.
Und auch das, die könnte ich die ganze Zeit filmen.
Aber kannst du bei iOS verbieten,
dass Apps Screenshots machen können?
Ach nee, warte mal, wie war das?
Bei Signal, auf Android ist es so, dass Signal den Betriebssystem verbietet, von Signals Oberfläche Screenshots zu machen.
Das geht auf iOS nicht mehr.
Früher ging sowas in der Art mal, da hast du es mitbekommen, bevor der Screenshot, du konntest irgendwie da einen Hook reinhaken und hast es mitbekommen.
Und so haben solche Apps zum Beispiel auch quasi ihr Logo davor geschaltet, wenn du ein Screenshot gemacht hast.
Mittlerweile kriegst du vom System nur noch die Notification, dass gerade ein Screenshot gemacht wurde.
Also du könntest das mitkriegen, also du könntest
die Info verarbeiten, dass der Nutzer das gemacht hat,
aber du bist quasi dahinter.
Was willst du denn dann machen?
Kernelpanic oder sowas?
Warum auch? Das ist das Gerät vom Nutzer, der soll doch screenshotten können, was er möchte.
Naja, der Zweck ist,
dass...
Andere Apps können dich nicht screenshotten, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Also du kannst wirklich nur in quasi deine eigene
UI kannst du in den
Bildrendern. Wahrscheinlich ist das der Grund, also wenn
das bei iOS eh so ist,
dann ist es ja in Ordnung. Ich glaube bei Android ist es so,
dass du halt prinzipiell andere Apps können halt Screenshots
vor dem gesamten Bildschirm machen.
Dann verstehe ich es absolut.
Dann ist das gar nicht geil,
dass eine App das nicht mitkriegen würde.
Dann würde ich das auch blocken wollen.
Auf jeden Fall.
Da gab es ja auch diesen witzigen Feature,
habe ich jetzt vor kurzem gelernt,
dass iOS-Apps anscheinend,
wenn du einen Bildschirm dranhängst,
können die andere UI auf dem externen Display anzeigen,
was eigentlich ziemlich cool ist.
Und da hat ja auch Ben im Swift Slack gemeint,
dass N26, diese Banking, diese Fintech-Smart-Up,
Die haben sie mittlerweile wohl leider nicht mehr drin, aber hatten damals das drin, dass die auf dem externen Monitor einfach nur ein Werbevideo angezeigt haben, was erst mal dumm klingt, aber das war wohl explizit ein Sicherheitsfeature, wenn du deinen ganzen Screen irgendwo hinmirrorst über Airplay, am Fernseher oder so und dann wechselst du deine Banking-App, dann willst du nicht allen plötzlich deine Banking-Daten zeigen.
Und das war halt einfach nur abzusichern, es gibt nicht wirklich einen guten Use-Case dafür, dass du deinen Banking-Shit am Fernseher machen möchtest über Kabel oder Airplay, aber für den Fall, dass du es aus Versehen machst, we got you.
Ja, das ist cool.
Das muss man dann nur gerade ein Werbevideo zeigen.
Man könnte auch in dem Moment sagen,
ich verpixel jetzt alles oder sowas.
Ja, also es ist quasi ein Logo angezeigt
und irgendein Video, ich weiß nicht mehr,
was das genau war. Ich hab das nie gesehen, das Feature in
Action. Ach, ich hab übrigens,
während du gerade geredet hast, mal heimlich
nachgeguckt. Also es gibt irgendwie
Thunderbird.net.
Das ist die neue Webseite von Thunderbird.
Und Thunderbird war ja lange Zeit so ein,
ähm, wie nennt man es?
Keep the light on?
Projekt von
KTLO-Projekt von
Mozilla, wo nicht viel passiert ist.
Oder wie nennt man so ein Abstellgleis-Projekt?
Abstellgleis-Projekt.
Das läuft noch.
Müssen wir jetzt nicht mehr viel dran machen.
Allerdings ist da wieder eine neue Bewegung reingekommen und irgendwer
hat es angefangen zu finanzieren.
Hier steht es nicht wirklich drin.
Aber es ist jetzt eine private...
As of today,
the Thunderbird Project will be operating
from a new wholly owned
Subsidiary of the Mozilla Foundation
MCLA Technologies.
Dann haben sie also eine neue Firma
gegründet und haben auch neue Entwickler
eingestellt und seit Anfang dieses Jahres ist
auf Thunderbird wieder Betrieb.
Nicht schlecht, finde ich cool.
Sollte nicht sterben. Tolles Projekt.
Ja, ich benutze es auch noch aktiv.
Ich meine, dann kommt mal jemand mit einem neuen
E-Mail-Client um die Ecke.
Ich bin Mail-App-User, aber
Thunderbird war immer toll.
Ja, Mail-App habe ich auch immer mal ausprobiert,
aber Thunderbird finde ich tatsächlich immer noch
funktionaler. Es ist nicht so schick.
Das ist Gewohnheitssache, klar,
auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe mich nie daran gewöhnt, aber
ist bei uns einfach genau geflippt.
Genau. So, was haben wir
denn noch so für Projekte? Achso, ein ähnliches
Thema, das ist auch eine ganz kurze Headline,
die ich jetzt neulich mitbekommen habe
und groß gefeiert habe, ist das,
was ähnlich jetzt
auch mit
Servo passiert ist.
Servo war ja auch so dieses
Forschungsprojekt von Mozilla
mit dem Forschungsbrowser.
an dem gearbeitet wurde und dummerweise
hatte ja Mozilla, das ist auch so ein Thema, was
in unserer Podcastpause passiert ist,
Mozilla hatte so eine große
Entlassungswelle
vor ein, zwei Monaten
gehabt, wo sie 250 Leute auf einmal rausgeschmissen
haben.
Da gab es dann so herrliche
Mozilla Lifeboat oder so, was hieß das
doch, diese Mozilla Lifeboat.
Genau, Lifeboat.com.
Kann sein, dass wir darüber tatsächlich in der letzten Folge
gesprochen haben? Das kann sein, dass wir darüber
geredet haben.
zumindest ist da das gesamte
Servo-Team
entlassen worden
wo sich alle gedacht haben
wisst ihr überhaupt noch was ihr macht, weil das ist ja quasi die Zukunft
auch aus Browsers, die ihr da mit beerdigt
und jetzt ist
Servo
ist in die Arme von
der Linux Foundation
gelaufen, das klingt schlecht
ist jetzt neu beheimatet
im Haus der
Linux Foundation, genau, das ist jetzt so ein
Linux-Foundation-Projekt, was ich ganz cool finde.
Die Webseite hat gleich irgendwie ein neues Logo
und hat ein bisschen ein Update, ein visuelles
Update bekommen.
Ja, das spricht auf jeden Fall
auch für die Langlebigkeit des Projektes, glaube ich,
auch mit. Also, das ist jetzt gut beheimatet
und wird noch gut lange weitergeführt.
Auf jeden Fall. Also, ich hoffe auch, dass da
irgendwann wirklich ein
produktiver
Browser draus wird.
Diese ganzen Browser-Engines,
dass es da nur noch zwei von gibt, ist ja
leider ein bisschen sehr traurig.
Ich habe da auch so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, dass
Mozilla über kurz oder lang
die ganzen Entwicklungen
im Browser-Technologie-Markt
einfach nicht mithalten kann.
Wenn alle anderen
Industrien, das ist, Chrome ist
jetzt so eine Art Linux-Körnel,
das Web und jeder
Global Player arbeitet an
Chromium und an WebKit
oder an Chromium, ist ja
mittlerweile gefolgt.
Mittlerweile ist gut. WebKit ist mittlerweile
anderes. Blink ist das, was du suchst.
Genau. Ja, gut.
Anyway, die meisten da sitzen
auf Blink und dann ist halt noch Apple
mit WebKit und ein paar andere,
die WebKit mit benutzen, aber die Hauptentwickler
von WebKits ist, glaube ich,
ausschließlich Apple, wenn ich es richtig verstehe.
WebKit ist jetzt nur noch Safari, genau.
Und
für alle, die Firefox benutzen,
besteht natürlich dann immer die Gefahr, wenn jetzt der nächste
Standard in den Browser
landet, dann ist Firefox
dahinter her. Und ich meine, man sieht es auch. Es gibt viele Sachen,
die mich in meiner täglichen
Arbeit betreffen, die in Firefox einfach
längst nicht so flutschen
wie in Chrome leider. Das fängt
bei so Sachen wie WebRTC
an. Das ist
vom Feature-Set und von den Möglichkeiten
in Chrome einfach mal
Güteklasse A und in
Firefox leider nur Güteklasse B.
Safari C.
Und Safari
hat
jetzt einfach mal gesagt,
gut, wir updaten mal unseren Fork von WebRTC,
den wir aus Chrome geklaut haben in Safari
und hat mittlerweile den gleichen WebRTC-Support wie Chrome.
Weil sie einfach mittlerweile mal ihre Version geupdatet haben.
Wenn ich mich richtig erinnere,
ich habe es noch nicht wirklich intensiv ausprobiert,
aber das ist alles.
Und Firefox hat halt seine eigene Version von sowas.
Und dann gibt es dann die nächsten geilen Sachen,
die am Horizont zu sehen sind.
Bei mir, das Einzige, was mir jetzt einfällt, ist sowas wie Web-Audio
oder Web-Codex und solche Sachen.
Die sind einfach immer als erstes in Chrome da.
Hauptsächlich auch, weil Google halt diese Entwicklung ganz dolle pusht.
Und bei Firefox taucht es dann ein bisschen später auf.
Ein bisschen später kann er noch manchmal zwei oder drei Jahre sein.
Das ist sehr traurig.
Mal schauen. Hoffentlich wird Gekko nicht sterben.
beziehungsweise durch Servo ersetzt irgendwann,
aber hoffentlich Firefox nicht sterben.
Genau, jetzt ist meine Frage.
Jetzt hat sich Firefox oder Mozilla
hat sich mit seiner Kündigungswelle da
dem Servo-Team entledigt.
Und jetzt ist Servo ein unabhängiges,
Mozilla-unabhängiges Produkt.
Hat allerdings natürlich technologisch noch
sehr viel Verwandtschaft mit dem Firefox-Projekt,
kann ich mir vorstellen.
Das ist schon so, dass Firefox am ehesten
eine Heimat für neue Servo-Komponenten wäre.
Die Frage ist, profitiert
jetzt Firefox weiterhin
von Features, die
von
Server entwickelt werden?
Oder muss es dazu erst
einen neuen Browser geben, der komplett auf
Server basiert? Das finde ich mal, das ist eine spannende
Frage. Oder nimmt jemand Firefox
und forked Firefox und sagt,
wir sind jetzt diejenigen, die
Server-Features
da einbauen. Also diese ganze
Browser-Welt bleibt spannend. Ich finde,
schön, dass das Servo-Projekt definitiv
jetzt erstmal nicht tot ist.
Es sind auch noch fast genau die
gleichen Leute, die an Servo weiterarbeiten
wie bislang.
Und es
freut mich auch persönlich für die
Leute, die da dran arbeiten. Ein paar von denen
durfte ich ja auch mal ganz kurz
kennenlernen.
Und ja,
es freut
mich auf jeden Fall für das Projekt.
Die Monokultur ist
noch nicht ganz da.
hoffen wir, dass es so bleibt.
Sich weiter in die Richtung
entwickelt. Genau.
Was haben wir denn noch für Themen?
Wir haben noch einen herrlichen, naja,
Fuck-up in Anführungsstrichen.
Und zwar geht der in Richtung GitHub diesmal.
Beziehungsweise Microsoft, nachdem
jemand sehen möchte. Aha, wo kommst du
gerade hin? Ich hab das geholfen. Okay.
In Zeile 3
ist etwas versteckt. Ach der, ach so.
Ah ja, verstehe.
Und zwar hat GitHub
einen DMCA-Request bekommen.
Und das Blöde an DMCA-Takedown-Notices
ist halt, dass du die machen musst.
Und zwar jetzt.
Und nicht diskutieren, sondern
du machst das jetzt.
Du machst das und kannst im Nachhinein
drüber reden, aber du machst das erstmal.
GitHub hat halt nicht darüber geredet
im Nachhinein, weil warum auch? Die kriegen ja auch,
weil sie DMCA-Takedown-Notices, aber die haben halt
dann erstmal das Repo von YouTube.dl
offline genommen, beziehungsweise alle Forks, alles gelöscht.
Ich weiß nicht, gelöscht
Gelöscht bedeutet bei denen, aber spielt auch keine Rolle.
Das ist ein Git-Report, also das war erstmal weg.
War unerreichbar auf getappt.com.
Und das waren wohl irgendwelche Rechteinhaber von Musik.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, welche Firmen dahinter standen.
Irgendwelche Content-Mafia-Strukturen, die gesagt haben,
hey, YouTube DL, damit wird doch Copyright umgangen
und Musik von YouTube runtergeladen.
Musik, für die nur eine Streaming-Lizenz verfügbar ist,
aber keine Download-Lizenz.
Und das ist ja gar nicht das Gleiche, weil wenn du streamst,
dann landet das ja nicht auf deinem Computer,
sondern das landet ja direkt auf den Ohren.
Und deswegen haben sie diese DMCA-Takedown-Notes geschickt
und GitHub hat halt reagiert und das Ding gelöscht,
was scheiße war.
Vor allem, weil YouTube DL halt keine böse Software ist.
Also böse im Sinne von Piraterie.
Nicht, dass ich das sage, dass es generell böse ist,
aber YouTube DL hat halt nichts Falsches gemacht.
Und YouTube DL hat halt nur,
es hat nicht mal irgendwelche Copyright-Sachen,
kein DL-Umgang oder so.
Hat halt wirklich bloß Medien runtergeladen,
die den Rechner eh runterlädt.
Und YouTube DL macht ja auch nicht nur YouTube.
YouTube.de ist ja mega geile Software. YouTube.de kann ja
sogar die ZDF-Mediatek. YouTube.de
kann ja alles, literally alles, jede
Webseite, wo du ein Video anzeigst. YouTube.de kann wirklich
alles Mögliche runterladen
und wenn es das noch nicht kann, kannst
du wissen, dass es dafür bereits ein
Ticket gibt auf deren GitHub-Projekt.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Also es kann wirklich alles
runterladen, nutze ich wirklich sehr, sehr häufig.
Das Tool ist sehr angenehm.
Es wirft die Frage auf, ob der Name
YouTube.de noch...
Nee, der ist halt historisch da gewesen.
Richtig geil finde ich auch zum Beispiel,
dass mein Medienplayer of choice, INA mit Doppel-I, auf macOS,
der hat YouTube-DL integriert und kannst du direkt sagen,
hier Command-Shift-O, Web-URL reinpasten
und dann spielt er das einfach in den Player ab.
Finde ich sehr viel angenehmer,
als so manche lahme Web-Anwendungen zu nutzen.
Ist sehr, sehr angenehm.
Und war halt blöd, dass YouTube-DL da nicht verfügbar war.
Es ist halt ein bisschen um die Welt gegangen,
von wegen, was soll das?
Die können doch nicht einfach da freidrehen und Bullshit löschen,
was immer sie möchten.
Ist ja auch echt scheiße, dass sowas gemacht war.
Das ist auf einmal immer wieder in Erinnerung,
dass diese gesetzliche Grundlage,
dass man da sofort drauf reagieren muss, auch Quatsch ist.
Das ist schon richtig eklig.
Das ist einfach ein Zensurmittel, was du da hast.
Absolut, genau das ermöglicht so ein Shit eben auch.
Und netterweise hat es sich aber,
erst mal sehr cool, kurz danach haben Leute angefangen,
YouTube-DL halt auf die verschiedenste Art und Weise zu teilen.
Am coolsten fand ich fast die als Grafik-Encodierte,
als Grafik inkludierte Tarball auf Twitter,
den du dir runterladen konntest.
Großartig, hat die Kompression von Twitter überlebt.
Homebrew ist auch direkt
auf die YouTube-DL-Sourcen
auf PyPy umgestiegen, um die von da runter
zu ziehen. Auch großartig.
Also war halt überhaupt nicht groß
effektet gewesen.
Ganz viele Leute haben es erstmal geforkt, nachdem
es wieder irgendwo aufgetaucht war.
Ja, das Herrlichste fand ich noch,
ist, dass jemand dieses GitHub-Feature
ausgenutzt hat, dass du ja einen Pull-Request
zu einem Repo stellen kannst und der Content
des Pull-Requests dann im Repo-Tree schon mit
verfügbar ist. Du kannst Pull-Requests ja nicht löschen
auf GitHub. Ich glaube, mittlerweile vielleicht sogar schon,
aber du kannst sie theoretisch
schließen, aber der
Content, der da ist, der ist halt in dem
Repo, in dem Tree verfügbar, für immer.
Der hat halt eine eindeutige URL mit einem
Hash. Und jemand hat halt das
GitHub-DMCA-Repo, wo die alle
DMCA-Takedown-Ordes, die sie bekommen, mit
Publishing genommen, dann PR gestellt,
den Content ersetzt durch den YouTube-DL-Source.
Und YouTube-DL war halt auf
DMCA verfügbar.
Das fand ich schon schön. Das war aber eine nette
Aktion. Ach, herrlich.
Mittlerweile hat sich dann aber die
EFF stark gemacht und
GitHub kontaktiert und gemeint, hier
Leute, das ist schon scheiße, das
macht halt gar nichts an DRM-umgehenden
Kram oder so, das ist absolut nicht valide,
dieser DMCA-Takedown-Out.
Das geht so nicht.
Die EFF ist ja auch eine super tolle
Gruppe von Menschen, die
halt auch die Möglichkeit haben, da auf
rechtliche Sachen zurückzugreifen und da halt eben finanzielle Mittel und Anwälte zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und GitHub hat dann, oder beziehungsweise Microsoft, je nachdem, wer da jetzt wo mit drin hängt,
hat halt irgendwo eingesehen und darauf reagiert und mittlerweile das YouTube-DL-Webohr wieder aktiv geschaltet.
Also es ist wieder da, es lebt wieder.
Es ist schön, dass das zurückgängig gemacht wurde, auch als Zeichen,
dass eben diese DMC-Takedown-Ouses nicht in jedem Fall erfolgreich sind, egal was du damit zensieren möchtest.
Aber es wurde wieder rückgängig gemacht.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr toll.
Das rechne ich GitHub auch an der Stelle recht hoch an,
dass sie das gemacht haben.
Wenn sie jetzt noch ihre Verträge mit Ice canceln,
dann wäre das super.
Aber das ist noch nicht passiert.
Das haben ja Leute immer noch in ihren Twitter-Handles drinstehen.
Abolish Ice.
Ja, ist ja auch richtig.
Es ist ein schrecklicher, schrecklicher Verein,
die Kinder in Käfige sperren, die gehören verboten.
Oder beendet, wie auch immer man das bezeichnet.
Aber lass uns nicht über US-Politik reden,
da könnten wir auch nochmal eine Stunde
Podcast füllen.
Das ist gut in die Podcast-Pause gefallen, stimmt.
Ja, ja.
Da weiß ja mittlerweile auch, glaube ich, jeder auf diesem Planeten
Bescheid, was da Sache war.
Das muss man nicht rehaschen hier.
Nee, nee.
Wir hatten ganz kurz an dem Wahltag
ein Meeting, da gab es ja Kollegen in den USA.
Da habe ich auch so gesagt, ja, the world is watching.
Ja, das erinnert mich an so einen schönen Tweet
von irgendjemandem, ich glaube aus einem asiatischen Raum
irgendwo, meinte von wegen hier
in einem Staat, von deren Existenz
ich bis eben nicht mal wusste, zählen Leute
Stimmen und ich verfolge das live mit
für eine Wahl in einem Land, das ich noch nie
besucht habe, wahrscheinlich nie besuchen werde.
Aber heute ist das einfach das Ding
im Internet, wo jeder drauf schaut.
Auf jeden Fall.
So, krass. Ja, so viel
zum Thema YouTube.de.
Ich habe, glaube ich, noch einen Fork in meinem
Gitterprofil-Rounding.
Der bleibt da aber auch erstmal, auch wenn
Version vielleicht irgendwann ein bisschen zu veraltet ist.
Irgendwann?
Du meinst instant. Das Ding ist so viel, jeden Tag gibt's Updates.
Es gibt irgendwie, ich weiß, es gibt bei
war das bei GitHub?
Es gibt irgendwie dieses Master
Syncing oder sowas oder dieses
Branch Syncing Feature. Es kann auch sein, dass es ein
Bitbucket Feature ist, wo du sagst, wenn ich jetzt
was forke,
dann gab's irgendwo, es kann bei Bitbucket
gewesen sein, gab's eine
Checkbox, wo du sagen kannst,
halt es mal bitte synchron, halt es mal bitte
aktuell.
Das könnte GitHub echt mal gebrauchen.
Das wäre ganz gut.
Jedes Mal, wenn einer auf Master Merge,
dann sind die ganzen Forks auch automatisch aktualisiert.
Das wäre ganz cool.
Und wenn jemand DMCA Take-Down-Notes postet,
wird dein Fork gleich mitgelöscht.
Aber wäre ja sowieso.
Das machen sie ja schon.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall ganz gut.
Stell dir mal vor, jeder GitHub-Account
fork dann dieses Repo.
Dann hast du es irgendwie
100.000 Mal
als Fork bei GitHub.
Ich hoffe, die deduplikaten da schon recht sinnvoll im Hintergrund,
weil ich meine, es gibt ja sehr populäre Rebos,
die sehr häufig geforkt wurden.
Das wäre ziemlich dumm,
da eigentlich die Kopien komplett vorzuhalten, oder?
Ich meine, das ist ja gerade das Schöne an Git,
dadurch, dass die Commits halt eindeutig gehasht und signiert sind,
beziehungsweise eindeutig gehasht, meine ich,
dass du halt weißt, dass das derselbe Content ist.
Da kannst du das doch auch sicherlich gut deduplizieren.
Ach, übrigens zum Thema GitHub-Hashes.
Danke für deinen Pick vom letzten Mal.
Git-Vanity-Hash. Bei mir auf der Arbeit
ist leider noch niemandem aufgefallen,
dass alle meine Commits jetzt mit Coffee
anfangen.
Großartig.
Finde ich super.
Es hat leider einen Bug.
Also nochmal Git-Vanity-Hash.
Als Rückblick zum letzten Mal, es ist ein Tool,
was dir deine Git-Hash ändert
zu etwas, was
dann einfach mit einem
Vanity-String anfängt. Da kannst du dann halt
1337 oder Coffee oder
Cafe Babe oder sowas. Oder sie einzeln
hochzählen lassen.
Oh, auf jeden Fall. Nicht schlecht.
Ja, das kommt mit eins, kommt mit zwei.
Machst du diese Kopfschmerzen beim Rebase,
das aufrecht zu erhalten?
Ja, ich habe auch,
mir fällt auch gerade nicht ein, also ich,
was ich glaube ich nicht hinkriege, ist, wenn ich was
wenn ich vergessen, wenn ich schon zwei
Commits gemacht habe und beim ersten vergessen habe,
das zu machen, wüsste ich jetzt nicht aus dem
Stehgreif, wie ich das auf den
zweiten Anwender, auf den ersten Anwender
drückwirkend. Aber egal, zumindest
benutze ich das recht gut.
Das hat leider einen Bug.
Und zwar sagt es dir nicht,
wenn der Vanity-String, den du da eingibst,
dass der nicht darstellbar ist.
Sondern das versucht es dann einfach.
Ich habe mal irgendwann... Hast du Emoji reingepackt?
Ja, ich habe mal irgendwas mit...
Ich habe versucht, Hendrik zu schreiben oder sowas.
Zum Spaß, da war schon was passiert.
Ich hätte mir ja sagen können, kann ich mit
Hexadizimalstellen nicht abbilden.
Tut mir leid.
Stattdessen rechnet er halt so lange, bis er es zufällig findet.
Und da wird einfach dein Computer sehr heiß.
Könnte man dann Ischima aufmachen.
Venture ist es mittlerweile auch gefixt,
aber soviel zum Thema Gebt Vanity Hash.
Wo wir gerade bei CPUs und wie man sie am effizientesten nutzt sind,
da ist jetzt noch ein anderes News-Thema,
was wir in unserer Liste haben.
Jo, und zwar hat Apple da vor kurzem angekündigt,
beziehungsweise vor einer ganzen Weile schon angekündigt,
aber gesagt, dass sie das bis zum
Jahresende rausbringen, ihre eigene
CPU-Architektur für den Mac.
Das sind jetzt diese M1-Chips, die
in der ersten Generation rausgekommen sind, die M1-Chips
in Form von
einem Mac Mini, einem MacBook Air und einem MacBook Pro.
Und also
die Präsentation fand ich ganz nett,
aber die Daten
waren halt schwach. Also sie haben halt nichts
quasi darüber gesagt. Keine wirklichen
Zahlen, nur Graphen und Nachkennschriften.
als sie es noch unter dem Namen Apple Silicon angekündigt haben.
Nee, nee, die Präsentation jetzt vor ein paar Wochen,
wo sie, oder zwei Wochen, wann das war,
wo sie die Macs vorgestellt haben.
Damals, als sie vor einem halben Jahr oder wann das war,
Apple Silicon vorgestellt haben,
haben sie auch natürlich nicht viel was dazu gesagt,
außer von wegen, das kommt.
Und es gibt dieses DTK, dieses Developer Tool,
vergessen wir, wo es DTK steht, Tech irgendwas.
Ich dachte eigentlich Preview, aber da ist ja kein P drin.
Wo sie quasi ein Mac Mini mit einem iPad-
Das kannst du einfach, oder? Ach so, wahrscheinlich.
Das eben
konntest du beantragen, beziehungsweise kaufen für
500 Dollar als Leihgabe.
Haben sie ja damals auch schon gemacht,
als sie von PowerPC auf Intel umgestiegen sind,
auf dieselbe Art und Weise.
Und da haben sie halt nicht wirklich was gesagt,
außer das Ding ist nicht das, was
später im Jahr rauskommen wird, weil es ist ja
explizit eine iPad-CPU, die da drin war. Bloß das ist halt
das Instruction-Set
quasi. Also du kannst darauf testen, ob deine Apps
laufen und deine Apps mal dagegen entwickeln und schauen,
was kaputt geht und was du fixen musst.
aber das ist leistungsmäßig
überhaupt nicht vergleichbar mit dem was da kommt
mehr haben sie nicht wirklich gesagt und jetzt vor zwei
Wochen haben sie eben die ersten Macs gezeigt
und das war wie gesagt der Mac Mini also ein Desktop Rechner
und zwei Laptops und
haben halt aber in der Präsentation selber
nicht viel zu spezifischer Leistung
gesagt, sie haben gesagt das Ding ist so und so viel
schneller als ein Windows
Ja aber dann
so sinnlose Sachen wie als ein Windows
Rechner in its price class
was bedeutet das?
Das ist gar nichts. Aber wir haben auch
überhaupt keine Achsenbeschriftung gehabt, natürlich nicht.
Ist ja nicht schön, ich bin erst beim Mouse-Over,
so wie alles in Big Sur.
Ist das kein Mouse-Over mehr beim Big Sur?
Nee, das ist so ein typisches
Kritikpunkt, dass Apple jetzt je kichig UI
versteckt, bis du mit der Maus drüber hovers.
Also wenn du eine Notification kriegst, siehst du dieses X
nicht, bis du mit der Maus drüber gehst.
Oder dass du die Time Remaining
im Music Player nicht siehst, bis du mit der Maus drüber gehst.
Ich finde das ein bisschen affig.
Das können sich schon wieder ein bisschen mehr anzeigen.
Ich habe das Screen Real Estate, ich sitze hier vor einem riesigen
Monitor. Ich würde gerne auch sehen, was passiert.
Ja, vor allem, wenn du deine Maus nicht wirklich aktiv nutzt.
Das geht mir nicht.
Eben, aber das haben wir dahingestellt. Darum geht es gerade nicht.
Genau.
Aber sie haben halt
nicht viel dazu gesagt gehabt.
Also sie haben gesagt, die Dinger sind schnell,
aber nicht wie schnell. Und die Dinger
haben maximal 16 GB RAM und da haben alle
drüber gedacht, 16 GB RAM, was ist denn das für ein
MacBook Pro? Was ist denn das für eine Pro-Maschine
mit 16 GB RAM? Ach so, das haben sie auch noch
gesagt. Genau.
Und das ist halt alles, was letztendlich an Infos kam.
Finde ich viel mehr als das.
Also die Dinger sind schneller als andere Geräte.
Cool.
Gibt es jetzt eine neue Generation von MacBook Pros
mit dem alten Chip noch?
Ach nee, die haben nicht wirklich die Rechner aktualisiert.
Die Macs und iMacs.
Nee, Quatsch.
Die Mac Minis.
Und das ist eine richtige Apple-Folge übrigens hier gerade.
Vielleicht wird das doch unter Hello Swift einfach veröffentlichen.
Die Mac Minis und die MacBooks sind noch genau die gleichen Geräte
wie die aktuelle 2020er-Generation.
Also sie sehen identisch aus, aber das Logicboard ist halt neu.
Und da ist halt der neue Chip drin.
Also den Mac Mini und das MacBook Air haben sie komplett ersetzt.
Da gibt es die alte Version nicht mehr.
Beim MacBook Pro haben sie wirklich bloß die Einsteiger-Config ersetzt.
Die, die du vorher auch mit maximal 60 GB RAM bekommen hast.
Das andere 13-Zoll-Mac Pro, das höhere,
also das ist quasi nicht das Übergangsgerät zwischen dem Pro und dem Air,
Das haben sie ersetzt, aber das echte 13-Zoll-Macro Pro noch nicht.
Und die ganzen höheren Geräte wie die größeren Macro Pros,
den iMac, die Mac Pros und so, die kommen alle später noch,
haben sie gesagt.
Also sie wollten erst dieses Jahr mit den kleinen Geräten anfangen.
Und die Leute waren halt die Frage offen,
was genau haben die Dinger für eine Leistung?
Wie performen die im Alltag?
Genau.
Und jetzt sind die halt die ersten auch angekommen
und die Embargos wurden geliftet und die Reviewer,
die die Geräte schon bekommen haben,
haben da Informationen zu gepublished.
Und ich muss sagen, ich bin ziemlich beeindruckt.
die Dinger sind echt fucking schnell.
Also genaue Daten sind natürlich nicht bekannt,
aber ich weiß gar nicht, was man groß darüber aussagen könnte,
wenn du jetzt weißt, wie viel Megahertz so ein Ding hat,
wie es getaktet ist, weil das ist halt nicht so das Relevante,
wenn das halt eine komplett andere Architektur ist,
die sich anders benimmt,
dann kannst du das halt nicht so direkt vergleichen.
Es kommt halt wirklich darauf an,
zum einen kannst du natürlich Benchmarks anschauen
und da ist es schon beeindruckend,
weil dieses MacBook Air, was nicht mal eine aktive Kühlung hat,
das ist komplett ruhig,
wenn das halt so ein iMac der vorherigen Generation
halt komplett hinten dran lässt.
Das kann doch nicht sein.
Das ist lächerlich schnell.
Und dann gibt es auch noch die Mac Mini.
Das MacBook Air ungekühlt ist schneller
als eine vorherige Generation iMac.
Ja.
Bei was?
Bei den Benchmarks, die sie gemacht haben.
Bei Geekbench Benchmarks.
Und das war halt schon beeindruckend.
Und das Ding hat keine aktive Kühlung.
Und jetzt haben halt Leute angefangen, hier wirklich
Real-World-Usage rauszuhauen.
Also jetzt für Leute, die die Verbindung nicht herstellen,
Wenn das Ding keine aktive Kühlung hat,
dann muss es natürlich auf eine gewisse Art und Weise runter takten,
weil es ja beim Arbeiten Hitze produziert.
Und deswegen kannst du es nicht das gesamte Potenzial ausnutzen.
Was ich spannend finde, ist,
dass sie wirklich genau die gleiche CPU in die einfachen Geräte,
also in das MacBook Air, was ja wirklich kein Leistungsgerät ist,
und in das MacBook Pro einbauen.
Das sind halt alles die einfachen Geräte.
Also das ist halt die Einsteigergruppe.
Das MacBook Pro, genau das MacBook Pro mit dem Apple Silicon Chip
ist halt nicht wirklich ein Pro-Gerät. Es heißt halt
nur so. Aber
das Ding performt halt erstaunlich gut.
Und Leute bauen jetzt ihre Projekte damit
in Xcode und schauen, wie das schneller läuft
und machen damit Schnitte in Final Cut
und machen sonst was und probieren immer aus.
Und es performt halt alles fantastisch.
Das Ding ist, also
es ist nicht nur schnell im Alltag, so im Sinne von
du öffnest ein Programm und es ist instant da oder du öffnest
das Gerät und es ist halt instant wach,
sondern das macht halt auch Dinge wirklich schneller
und das ist sehr angenehm. Und da haben
sie natürlich noch diese Emulationsschicht.
mit diesem Rosetta 2, was dir die
x86-Apps halt noch weiter lauffähig hält.
Du willst ja nicht plötzlich hier nur noch
für Apple Silicon kompilierte
Apps laufen lassen. Kannst ja auch nicht. Es gibt ja auch Apps, da wird es
nie eine Apple Silicon-Variante davon geben.
Vermutlich, vermutlich. Genauso wie
damals, als PowerPC-Apps
Apple auf Intel
umgestiegen ist, haben sie auch lange diese Rosetta
Schicht dazwischen gehabt, dass du PowerPC-Apps
starten konntest. Und das hat etliche Jahre
gedauert, bevor sie das irgendwann rausgeschmissen haben.
Da sind ein paar Legacy-Sachen dann vom Tisch gefallen, die
die nie Updates bekommen haben. Ist halt schade
drum, aber ich sehe auch ein, dass du das nie für immer
mitnehmen kannst. Ja, du möchtest auch nicht ewig
deine, dein, dein, dein,
möchtest auch nicht ewig dafür garantieren, dass
deine, dass die alten Binaries von vor
zehn Jahren immer noch auf deinem Betriebssystem laufen. Also wenn
du das machst, dann hast du entweder...
Windows macht das erstaunlich gut tatsächlich. Also da läuft wirklich
richtig uralter Shit immer noch. Ja, ich glaube, die haben direkt
mehrere
Emulationslayer da drin oder irgendwelche
Kompatibilitätsabstraktionen
für unterschiedliche Sachen.
Das ist auch echt sinnvoll. Also
Auf der Stelle kann ich was sehen, wenn
viele Leute dieses System halt nutzen und
ihre alte Buchhaltungssoftware, was weiß ich,
also das ist immer dieses Beispiel,
da haben wir am Laufen haben. Aber ich sehe auch ein, dass man das
nicht möchte, natürlich. Und wenn du es in
einige Jahren mit Support hast und du gibst den Sachen, die halt
noch aktiv maintained werden, die Chance, auf jeden Fall
auf den Zug aufzuspringen, dann machst du das
eigentlich schon ganz gut. Und Rosetta 2,
das ist halt das Erstaunliche, das performt auf dem
Apple Silicon Mac, performt eine App in
Rosetta 2, also mit der X83
Emulationsschicht, besser als auf dem Intel Mac.
Müsste man das nicht sogar direkt umjitten können,
dass du quasi sagst...
Das machen die tatsächlich. Genau das machen sie.
Es ist ja damit quasi keine...
Es ist ja nicht so was wie eine Virtualisierung.
Das ist jetzt ein bisschen out of my comfort zone,
aber ich möchte mir vorstellen,
dass du es einfach...
Dass sie bereits während des Entwicklungsprozesses
quasi so eine Art JIT-Compiler für x86
nach Apple Silicon gebaut haben.
Also du hast letztendlich zwei Sachen.
Also zum einen, ich nutze hier das Wort
Virtualisierungsschicht oder Emulationsschicht
frei, es ist nicht wirklich eine Emulation, die da passiert.
Zum anderen,
es gibt zwei Apps,
die du bauen,
du kannst eine App bauen, also eine gebundelte
Unified Binary, die beides beinhaltet.
Apple Silicon und Intel.
Universal Binary heißt das, glaube ich.
Genau, Universal Binary, genau.
Dann distribuiert es die
und dann nutzen deine Kunden automatisch
das Richtige, einwandfrei, perfekt.
Das ist super für die Zeit.
Das andere, was halt geht, ist, wenn du
eine x86-App auf einem
Apple Silicon Mac startest, dann macht der da
halt irgendwie, das haben sie erklärt, ich hab's mir
ganz im Kopf, aber der macht da irgendwie
so
eine, ich weiß nicht,
ob es so eine JIT-Sache ist oder ob die
da direkt beim Start schon haufenweise
Sachen wirklich umbauen.
Da wäre jetzt irgendwie einer von den Dresdner
Virtualisierungsexperten, die wir ja so viele haben,
mal ein spannender Gast irgendwie, das würde
mich mal interessieren. Ich hab übrigens grad nochmal nachgeschaut,
was die Übersetzung von Rosetta
angeht, bzw. Rosetta 2. Und zwar hatte
Rosetta 1
quasi, nämlich genau das gemacht. Das hat
in Realtime jede Instruction einfach übersetzt gehabt.
Und Rosetta 2 macht
das eben explizit nicht, beziehungsweise kann
das wohl auch, aber das macht das halt explizit
eigentlich zur Installationszeit,
wird die App schon
konvertiert und dann hast du eine ARM-Optimized
Version schon auf der Platte, bevor du sie überhaupt
geöffnet hast.
Es kann auch on the fly
das für Sachen machen, wo das nicht funktioniert.
So im Browser, Java
Oder JavaScript steht hier, so als Beispiele.
Aber das meiste wird zur Installationszeit eben direkt übersetzt.
Und so hast du diesen Performance-Hit dann nicht zur Runtime.
Wenn du eine Anwendung hast, die selber noch einen JIT-Compiler drin hat,
ist das natürlich was, was du brauchst. Das stimmt.
Klar.
Aber hat dir nicht Apple für iOS so eine Abstraktionsschicht sogar eingeführt?
Es gab noch Bitcode, meinst du vielleicht?
Ja, genau, dass du Swift nach diesem komischen Bitcode kompilierst.
Was hat denn das damit auf sich?
Der Vorteil von Bitcode war, dass du
das, was du an Apple schickst, kannst du
als Bitcode Binary bauen.
Und das ist ja noch so ein Mittelding
zwischen dem, was du letztendlich
ich will das böse Wort nicht in den Mund nehmen, das böse
K-Wort.
Ich hätte das ja in C geschrieben, aber stimmt.
Das, was am Ende rauskommt und das,
was du als Source bereitstellt hast,
da kommt so ein Mittelding irgendwo,
lange nach L wie MIR.
Und das ist das, was du Apple
Und Apple hat eben die Möglichkeit,
deine Binaries so für neue Architekturen,
die sie noch nicht haben,
neu zu bauen und zu optimieren.
Und kann somit irgendwelche Optimizations fahren
auf ihren Servern für deine Apps,
ohne dass du überhaupt involviert bist.
Ach so, ich dachte, das ist irgendwie gedacht,
dass das auf dem Telefon passiert oder sowas.
Soweit ich weiß nicht.
Soweit ich weiß, läuft das noch im App Store vorher.
Bei Android ist es ja so,
da ziehst du dir,
es ist teilweise so,
dass du, wenn du ein Betriebssystem-Update gemacht hast
oder wenn du dir so ein APK runtergeladen hast,
dann hat er teilweise gesagt, ich optimiere jetzt deine App.
Dann hat er quasi von den Java-Bitcode noch mal,
aber das auch weiter komplett aus meiner Konfession raus,
noch mal für dein konkretes Gerät...
Witzig, aber da hast du da natürlich eine viel größere Vielfalt an Geräten.
Das ist ja... Genau, deswegen.
Bei Android-Geräten hast du eine viel größere CPU-Vielfalt.
Bei Apple könnte ich mir jetzt vorstellen, dass sie das gemacht haben.
Naja, wir wollen ja irgendwann unsere ganzen Geräte,
auch die iOS-Anwendung auf Mac laufen lassen
oder vielleicht komplett neue Mac-CPU-Plattformen rausbringen,
wie sie jetzt halt gemacht haben.
Und da wäre es jetzt praktisch,
wenn deine Anwendung schon nach Bitcode kompiliert.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das nur für iOS gedacht war
oder auch für Desktop-Anwendungen.
Jetzt werden sie es vielleicht auch für die M1-Chips mitmachen,
aber das war primär für iOS gedacht.
Aber witzig, wenn du es schon ansprichst,
die M1-Chips haben natürlich auch den Vorteil,
dadurch, dass das halt eine Apple-eigene ARM-Architektur ist,
dass du die iOS-Apps direkt nativ darauf ausführen kannst.
Also du kannst dir alle iOS-Apps, die es gibt,
solange die Developer nicht ein Opt-out machen,
direkt aus dem App-Store runterladen.
Also jede iOS-App ist erstmal im App-Store,
im Mac-App-Store mit verfügbar.
Das finde ich auch ganz witzig.
Wieder was, was es mit Windows 8 gemeint hat.
Was ich eigentlich ganz cool finde,
wenn du, damit man das jetzt mal angesprochen hat,
ist, wenn ein Developer ein Opt-out macht,
sprich, wenn die Person nicht möchte,
dass die App im Mac-App-Store verfügbar ist,
dann kann man trotzdem die iOS-App ja runterladen als IPA-Datei.
das, was die APK ist in der Android-Welt,
und die einfach starten auf dem M1-Chips,
kam jetzt raus, das geht auch einfach direkt.
So kannst du, wenn du alte Backups hast von irgendwelchen Apps,
die gar nicht mehr im App Store existieren,
oder wenn Developer eben nicht wollen, dass die App im Store ist,
sowas wie zum Beispiel die Spotify-App oder die Netflix-App,
Dinge, die halt sehr praktisch sind auf dem Mac,
weil sie nativ sind, so wie Spotify und Slack zum Beispiel,
und ein Stück schneller laufen können,
oder vielleicht auch aufgeräumter sind,
wenn du die UI-Desktop-Version nicht magst, wer weiß,
kannst du direkt die mobile nutzen.
Das finde ich auch ganz cool.
natürlich so ein bisschen geil.
Weil ich mich immer wundere, ich habe ja keinen Fernseher,
ich gucke dann
Netflix im Browser, aber
wenn dann die
iOS-App auf dem
Desktop nutzen können, wäre schon praktisch.
Ich weiß nicht, was
der große Vorteil ist dann.
Will wahrscheinlich ein bisschen weniger Last erzeugen.
Aber das war noch das andere Thema, genau.
Die Akkuleistung von den Geräten ist halt
erstaunlich.
Also der
eine Reviewer, wer war das?
MKBHD war das, glaube ich mal, Katz Brownlee.
der YouTuber, der hatte gemeint,
dass er das Gerät ausgepackt hat, geladen
gehabt und dann eine Woche lang benutzt hat
und nicht einmal am Kabel hatte.
Also vier, fünf Tage waren das bei ihm, glaube ich, was er damit meinte.
Das ist
schon ein krasser Unterschied. Das sind so
Arco-Advancements, die hast du eigentlich nicht bei
Hardware-Updates. Das führt sich dann
an wie
Anfang der 2000er, als du dein Handy
irgendwie einmal die Woche geladen hast.
Stimmt. Das einfach ewig gehalten hat.
Bloß, dass du es jetzt wesentlich häufiger
benutzt und wesentlich mehr damit machst.
Ja, ist schon krass.
Wie gesagt, ich finde es jetzt spannend,
was das bedeutet, was das für den Rest
der Laptop-Desktop
des Ökosystems bedeutet.
Wird interessante Implikationen haben.
Wann es die erste Linux-Distributionen
für diese Plattformen gibt,
was die Kompatibilität zu anderen
Desktop-Arm-Plattformen darstellt.
Ob du jetzt so ein Arm Windows 10
auf so einem M1
MacBook laufen lassen könntest.
Das ist halt das, was leider gerade gar nicht geht.
Das wäre cool, wenn das geht, aber Bootcamp
zum Beispiel, dass du die Möglichkeit hast, auf dem
Dualboot mit Windows zu machen, das ist aktuell
erst mal gestorben. Das gibt es jetzt nicht mehr.
Auf jeden Fall.
Das werde ich ein bisschen vermissen. Ich habe es nicht allzu häufig
genutzt, aber wenn, war es schon sehr praktisch.
Also du wirst es vermissen, wenn du dann irgendwann so ein Gerät hast mit
einem M1-Jet. Ja, also das wird ein paar
Jahre dauern hoffentlich, aber
ich würde es dann vermissen.
Ja, im Konjunktiv bleibend.
Ich habe mir ja zum Podcast
produzieren und Musik aufnehmen und
StarCraft-Spielen auch ein Mac Mini geholt gehabt
Anfang des Jahres und irgendwie drei
Wochen später war diese Ankündigung von Apple Silicon.
Da habe ich mir gedacht, na, super, hätte ich
jetzt warten müssen, aber dann hätte ich ein
Dreivierteljahr gewartet. Und jetzt gucke ich mir gerade
diesen Mac Mini an, den aktuellen
und der hat weniger Anschlüsse
hinten dran als das vorgegangen.
Bei Mini dachte ich, haben sie nichts gestritten.
Da haben sie tatsächlich zwei solche USB-4
oder Thunderbolt-Anschlüsse weggenommen.
Da hast du... Witzig.
USB-4, na gut, heißt es
vier. Ja, USB-C ist es beim aktuellen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es drei oder vier ist.
Der
vorherige hatte vier Anschlüsse, der
jetzt hat nur noch zwei.
Blöd. Aber okay.
Aber ist halt so.
Deswegen
schmeiße ich meinen ja auch nicht weg.
Na gut.
Ich habe genug Apple-Werbung gemacht. Ja, definitiv.
Also ich glaube,
die Folge kannst du, Akonomisierbar-Folge kannst du eigentlich
gleichzeitig auch noch auf den anderen Field packen. Zum Spaß.
Hallo, liebe Heilos,
Früftehörer.
Nee, nee, nee. Ja, was haben wir da
sonst noch so für Themen?
Weiß nicht, da stehen noch ein paar Sachen zu ein paar Sprachen.
Sehr viel passiert. Oh ja, Sprachen.
Ich hab dann immer, ich schmeiß immer mal so
Sprachen in
unsere Shownotes und nehme mir vor,
die bis dahin, bis zum nächsten Mal gelesen zu
haben oder mir angeschaut zu haben.
Und dann hab ich's häufig dann doch nicht geschafft, aber
so Sachen, über die ich in letzter Zeit gestoßen
bin, kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel zumindest mal
kurz anteasern. Es gibt irgendwie
DA-Script oder
Das Script.
Das Script.org. Das Logo.
Ich weiß nicht, hast du dir das Logo mal angeguckt von der Seite?
Geh mal hin zu Das Script.org.
Das sieht entweder aus, also ich würde
sagen, das sieht aus wie dieses alte Trabant-Logo.
Aber mich erinnert das gerade an irgendein
Sci-Fi-Shit. Also es sieht
ein bisschen aus wie dieser Opel-Blitz.
Ja, ganz schön. Aber dadurch, dass es
schräg ist, sieht es eher aus wie das Trabant-Zeichen.
äh und das ist auch
eine Skriptsprache, die so ähnlich wie
ähm
so ähnlich wie Chai-Skript
so möglichst gut in C++
zu ähm
integrieren ist irgendwie
immer noch Skriptsprache
aber streng typisiert und sehr ähnlich
an Ruby angelegt
das könnte dir eigentlich als Crystal-Fan gefallen
da steht extremely blazingly
fast
da warte ich ja einiges
ja auf jeden Fall
Das andere Lustige, was ich noch gesehen hatte
aus der Sprachwelt ist
LVortran.
Und zwar ist das einfach ein neuer
Vortran-Compiler auf LLVM-Basis.
Also die Sprache
ist nicht totzukriegen.
Was ich sehr lustig finde.
Hat auch eine, aber ich glaube,
die Webseite ist einfach irgendein Blog-Template.
Aber zumindest kannst du dir jetzt
auch mit dem
LLVM-Frontend
Vortran bauen.
Sehr schön.
wer es braucht.
Gut.
Ja, was gibt es denn sonst noch so für Themen?
Es ist zum Beispiel seit der
letzten Akronomisierbar-Folge ist
TypeScript 4.0
rausgekommen und
4.1 steht in den Startlöchern
und ist, glaube ich, für Ende diesen Monats
geplant.
Da sind auf jeden Fall, ja,
leider bei TypeScript ist die Version
nicht semantisch, das heißt 4.0 ist
kein Breaking Change, was auch ganz gut ist.
Die zählen einfach nach einer 3.9 kommt eine 4.0.
Einfach, weil es schön ist.
So funktionieren Zahlen nicht.
Nee, aber bei Programmiersprachen ist es auch mit dem Semantic Versioning
so ein bisschen schwierig.
Du weißt doch, was Breaking ist.
Du weißt, was Breaking ist.
Du machst halt nie Breaking Changes,
dann bleibst du für immer bei der 0.
Genau, aber die haben auch,
da sind immer mal Breaking Changes dabei, so subtile.
Wo sie in den Release-Veränderungen dann sagen,
ja, hier werden wir jetzt strikter oder so was.
Ach so.
hier können wir plötzlich was infirren, was wir vorher
nicht infirren konnten und deswegen könnte dein Code
an der oder der Stelle jetzt brechen.
Ist aber quasi so Teil der TypeScript-
Philosophie, dass sie sagen, wenn sie strikter werden können,
dann werden sie noch strikter. Und wenn du
was hast, was mit der nächsten Version von TypeScript
nicht kompiliert, dann ist es gut, dass das nicht
kompiliert und du solltest es möglichst fixen.
Das finde ich völlig in Ordnung. Das finde ich auch nicht als
Breaking Change. Also ich meine, klar, es ist ein Breaking Change
per Definition, aber ich würde für mich
persönlich gar nicht so werten. Es wird definitiv
aber unter dieser Überschrift dann in den
wenn was kaputt geht. Ist ja richtig.
Ist ja ein Maintenance-Aufwand, den du plötzlich hast, weil du es fixen musst.
Genau. Und was jetzt bei TypeScript
4.0 passiert ist,
das war, glaube ich, gar nicht mal
so krass.
Da gibt's jetzt so Sachen wie
Variatic Templates
und die benutzt man auch, wenn man
nicht gerade Library-Entwickler ist,
auch nicht ständig, aber es geht.
Das ist eigentlich ganz okay.
Ah, da fällt mir auf, das hätten wir ja nicht für irgendwas
benutzen können und ich hab's nicht gemacht.
Ah, ist gut, dass ich da mal
reingucke in die Changelogs.
Das wichtigste bei TypeScript 4.0 fand ich,
dass es jetzt ein
Deprecated-Tag gibt, der auch
von der Sprache gehonored wird. Das heißt,
wenn du so einen Doc-Comment
an deine Funktionen ranschreibst und die
Deprecated nennst, dann taucht sie zumindest
in der IDE
als Deprecated auf. Und wenn du sie benutzt,
dann wird sie dir quasi von VS Code
als durchgestrichen dargestellt. Das ist ganz nice.
Ich hätte noch gerne irgendwie
einen Compiler-Fleck, wo du sagen kannst,
verbiete mal bitte alle
deprecated APIs,
so wie es jetzt gerade bei Rust ist,
dann kannst du bei jedem
Lint kannst du sagen
allow,
warn oder
deny und kannst quasi
von Anfang an sogar bei Lints, die normalerweise
entweder gar nicht an sind oder nur auf warn sind
bei deinem
Build-Prozess sagen,
verbiete dieses Lint auf jeden Fall.
Das hätte ich gerne noch bei TypeScript.
Das gibt es ja auch nicht.
Aber zumindest können wir jetzt
kommunizieren, wenn bestimmte Properties
oder Funktionen von
Klassen
gedeprecated sind. Das ist schon mal ein Schritt in die richtige Richtung.
Das richtig
krasse neue Feature ist allerdings bei TypeScript
4.1
Template Literal Types.
Okay, warte mal.
Ah ne, da hatten
die über das letzte Sprache gequatscht.
Du hast bei
TypeScript
TypeScript hat ja
Literal Types. Das heißt, du kannst
eine Variable haben, deren
Typ der String Hello World ist,
zum Beispiel. Und dann kannst du diese
Variable statisch
nur den Wert
Hello World zuweisen. Das ist sinnvoll
für so Tagging oder
für Enums.
Es gibt zwar Enums in TypeScript, aber die sind so
eigentlich soft deprecated. Die erzeugen
Runtime-Code und deswegen
das hat man früher an TypeScript so gemacht
und mittlerweile
möchte TypeScript allerdings keinerlei
Runtime-Code mehr erzeugen, deswegen sind Enums
eigentlich so ein bisschen
verpönt. Und anstatt Enums nimmt man
einfach Unions
von Typliteralen, das heißt du sagst
meine Variable
kann entweder diesen, diesen oder diesen
String annehmen und auf diese Art und Weise
machst du dann sowas wie Enums.
Das ist schon mal ganz cool, aber du kannst
halt damit nur konkrete Strings ausdrücken.
Du kannst halt sagen,
das hat entweder diesen
konkreten String, den ich irgendwo reinschreibe,
oder du kannst ein bisschen was Abgefahrenes damit
machen, was ich neulich schon mal beschrieben habe, dass du quasi
einen Typen hast, und wenn
du den parametrisierst mit
einer Klasse, dann ist es plötzlich
ein Union aus allen
Methodennamen
dieser Klasse.
Das ist sowas, was du mit Tags-Strips jetzt schon machen kannst.
Was du nicht machen kannst, ist diese
Strings verändern. Und da kommen jetzt
Template-Literal-Typen
ins Spiel.
Du kannst sagen, ein Typ ist ein, der Typ von dieser Variable ist dieser String.
Dann schreibst du anstatt einem String ein String-Template rein.
Also die, die du auch bei Ruby oder bei Swift hast, glaube ich auch,
wo du sagen kannst, hier mitten im String ist ein Platz,
halt dafür was anderes.
Dann wird das ausgefüllt.
Und damit kannst du jetzt so Sachen machen wie,
dieser Typ ist jetzt Hello World,
Und dieser andere Typ, wenn ich da diesen
Hello World Typen reinstecke, dann ist es plötzlich
unterstrich unterstrich Hello World oder
Hello World Capitalized.
Da kannst du es auch im Typsystem, kannst du auch
sagen, alles groß geschrieben.
Wir haben das jetzt zum Beispiel
großes Interesse daran, weil wir Typen abbilden
wollen. Wir haben so Payload Typen,
wo du was reinfüllst
und die sollen, wenn sie allerdings an die
Infrastruktur geschickt werden,
soll da irgendwie vor jedes Property
ein bestimmter Präfix davor.
Das willst du allerdings nicht an der Stelle, wo du das ausfüllst,
überall diesen Präfix hinschreiben müssen.
Also haben wir eine Funktion, die diese Präfixe
automatisch davor schreibt für die Properties.
Ist allerdings nicht wirklich typesafe abbildbar,
wenn du nicht für das Input und das
Output für beide Seiten
das Interface
zweimal schreibst, einmal mit und einmal
ohne Präfixe. Und selbst dann
ist die Umwandlung noch nicht so richtig typesafe,
weil du quasi, da hast du so einen kurzen Moment,
wo du sagst, ich kriege das hier rein, ich kann
genau testen, dass das andere rauskommt.
Aber der Compiler kann mir das halt nicht sagen.
Jetzt gibt es eine Möglichkeit, dass du eine Funktion schreibst,
wo du sagst, ich kriege dieses Objekt ohne Präfixe rein
und es gibt mir das gleiche Objekt, egal wie es aussieht,
mit Präfixen raus.
Das ist schon mal ziemlich nice.
Das macht das wirklich sehr angenehm, auf jeden Fall.
Oder du kannst sagen, gib mir alle,
du kannst also mittlerweile mit TypeScript einen Typen ausdrücken,
der sagt, mein Typ Fubar T,
wenn ich da in das T eine Klasse reinschreibe,
kriege ich den Namen aller Public-Funktionen,
die mit A anfangen.
oder die mit einem großgeschriebenen A
anfangen. Oder du kannst
sagen, gib mir mal die Liste aller Funktionen
von dieser Klasse in Capital
Letters oder sowas. Das ist schon mal ganz
cool. Was du damit allerdings
auch ausdrücken kannst, ist so,
dieser String, der hier reinkommt,
ist mir eigentlich egal, was der ist, aber der muss
irgendwie mit Anführungsstrichen anfangen und aufhören.
Dann ist es ein valider Typ.
Und als
das bekannt gegeben wurde, als ich mir dieses
Changelog mal kurz durchgelesen habe, dass das
dass das in TypeScript 4.1 landet,
da habe ich mir gedacht,
Moment, damit müsste man jetzt theoretisch auch
Parser schreiben können, oder?
Und habe dann auf Twitter
mal ganz kurz geschrieben,
I dare you to write a JSON-Parser-Wolf ist.
Und ohne Scheiß,
zwei Wochen später kommt einer
mit einer TypeScript-Typ-basierten
JSON-Parser-Library um die Ecke.
Das hat wirklich jemand gemacht.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt eine Library,
die macht nichts, die produziert keinen Code,
das ist einfach bloß Typen.
Aber wenn du diesen Typen in deinem Code verwendest,
kannst du eine Variable, die diesen Typen hat,
nur Strings zuweisen, die valides JSON sind.
Statisch.
Das ist schon geil.
Das ist ziemlich geil.
Das war die erste Ausbaustufe.
Das heißt, du hast jetzt irgendwie JSON im Typsystem möglich von TypeScript.
Das nächste, was jemand gebaut hat, ist SQL auf Basis von TypeScript-Typen.
Das heißt, du kannst einen Typen haben, der hat zwei Parameter,
einen String und ein Objekt.
Und der erste Parameter ist dann hoffentlich ein valides Stück SQL-Code.
Und wenn du dann als zweites ein Objekt reingibst oder ein Interface,
dann ist das Ergebnis ein neues Interface,
was quasi das Eingangsinterface war,
auf das dieser SQL-String angewendet wurde.
Mind equals blown.
Mir fehlen die Worte.
Also ich habe so ein bisschen Angst, was Leute damit machen werden.
Ah, ist schon cool.
Ich mag so Features, wo man so wirklich komplett quasi neue Kunst schaffen kann.
So Dinge, die man gar nicht erwartet.
Was zum Beispiel für viele Web-Anwendungen interessant ist,
es gibt ja so Routing in so Single-Page-Apps, wo du sagst,
dieser Unterpfad ist jetzt,
dieser Pfad ist diese Seite,
dieser Pfad ist diese Seite und es wird aber
alles von, ich weiß nicht,
Next.js oder React von so einem
Router innerhalb des Browsers gemacht.
Und diese Frameworks
haben jetzt die Möglichkeit, diese Router
Typesave darzustellen
oder auszudrücken. Das heißt, du kannst
sagen, hier, ich gebe jetzt hier einen String rein
und der testet
definitiv, dass dieser String
Slashes enthält und wenn du das durch Slashes
teilst, dann muss jeder Slash
irgendwie ein ausgefülltes
Feld, also jeder
Unterordner in deinem
durch Slashes getrennten Pfad
muss irgendwie von dir implementiert sein.
Das ist schon ziemlich cool, dass das jetzt geht.
Das ist wirklich ein cooler
Anwendung. Das ist ja was, was Swift hat.
Swift hat irgendwie das Konzept von Pfaden.
Nee.
Gibt's das nicht irgendwie?
Achso, du meinst die KeyPaths, ja.
Dass du quasi ein Pfad
in deine Attribute und Unter
Attribute, wie auch immer, durchgeben kannst.
Genau, das finde ich eigentlich ziemlich geil.
Ja, ich habe es am Anfang überhaupt nicht bestanden,
wofür man das haben möchte. Ich kannte das Feature in
irgendeiner anderen Serie, noch nie in einer anderen Sprache gesehen.
Aber tatsächlich, dass du halt
darüber irgendwelche abstrakten Sachen machen kannst, das ist
halt wirklich schon ganz cool, dass du halt quasi
sagen kannst, jede Funktion, die akzeptierten Keypath in so ein
Objekt rein, dann kannst du halt da Dinge
reingeben. Das ist
zum Beispiel was, was man in TypeScript jetzt
ausdrücken könnte. Du hast jetzt eine
Version, die nimmt
ein Objekt an und so einen Keypath,
Und keypath ist
foo.bar.5
für das fünfte Element aus einem Array,
was dann wahrscheinlich kommt, und so weiter
und so fort. Und du kannst jetzt
statisch prüfen, dass dieser Path, den du
da reingibst, wirklich valide
ein Ergebnis aus
diesem Interface, der rausgeben wurde.
Das ist ziemlich cool. So was habe ich mal in Rust
für YAML gebaut,
dass du sagst, ja, so eine Art
xpath oder
jsonpath.
Das ist cool.
Aber das muss ich wahrscheinlich für TypeScript jetzt nicht mehr bauen,
weil es garantiert jetzt schon irgendjemand gebaut hat.
Wahrscheinlich,
während wir diese Folge aufgenommen haben.
Wahrscheinlich schon bevor wir diese Folge
aufgenommen haben. Ich muss sie mal nochmal raussuchen.
Ich schmeiß mal ein paar Links zu dem Thema
in unsere Show Notes rein.
Wollen wir mal, ich glaube,
wir haben auch eine gute Menge aufgenommen,
zu unseren Picks übergehen noch?
Oh ja, das ist eine Idee. Wir haben eine gute Zeit erreicht
mittlerweile. Ich sag's ja nicht, aber wir haben eine gute Zeit erreicht.
Fangen du mal an.
Du hast schon was auf der Liste stehen.
Oh ja, auf jeden Fall.
Das ist der Moment, wo ich jetzt mein Audio-Setup
auf Lautsprecher umstellen muss.
Und zwar mein erster Pick ist
CCFXM.
Gibt es da irgendwie eine Art und Weise,
wie du das aussprechen würdest?
Naja, CCFX.
Würde ich gerade passen.
Und zwar ist das ein JavaScript Web Audio Beispiel.
Und zwar, wenn du mal auf diese Webseite gehst,
die ich da verlinkt habe,
ccfxm ist a tiny JavaScript Music Renderer.
Ach so, genau, ccfx ist was anderes.
Das ist tatsächlich so eine Art Synthesizer.
ccfx ist a JavaScript Sound Effect Engine and Creation Tool.
Das ist noch mal was ganz anderes.
Könnte man quasi direkt, ist direkt da drunter verlinkt.
Und das M ist jetzt ein Renderer.
Und wenn du ein bisschen rot auskürzt,
du siehst da, das ist einfach eine Funktion.
Und da gibst du jetzt Daten rein.
Und dann spielt der Musik.
Ich sehe da die Daten.
Das ist ja schrecklich.
So, da gibt es jetzt, warte mal, da gibt es irgendwie,
genau, also wenn du jetzt, da gibt es Examples unten.
Genau, da siehst du, meine Daten sind einfach,
das sind Zahlenarrays, Arrays von Zahlenarrays.
Und ich schätze mal, wenn man das formatiert,
erkennt man da irgendwie Tracks.
Und da kannst du dann auf Play drücken.
Das mache ich mal.
Ich höre es gerade schon.
Das ist das Cuddly-Demos im Hintergrund.
Das klingt geil.
Und das klingt dann so.
Und das wird gerade von meinem Browser gemacht.
Das ist mega cool.
Ein bisschen geil ist es.
Das ist der Hammer.
Das klingt auch geil.
So, das kannst du jetzt hinschreiben.
Und du embeddest das einfach bei dir.
und dann kannst du, damit kannst du zum Beispiel
die Musik auf deiner Webseite machen, wenn jemand
den Konami-Code eingibt.
Ja! Muss ich mal ersetzen, bevor ich da
irgendwann die MCA-Taked-Anoutes bekomme.
Cuddly Demos.
Wie klingt das?
Ja, das hattest du gerade an, ne?
Ja. Ist auch richtig geil
in Stereo, war richtig schön auf einem Kopfhörer.
Das finde ich immer total schlimm.
Ich hab, äh,
was höre ich immer,
auf YouTube guckt diesen
Marble Machine X-Channel,
wo dieser Wintergatan-Typ
die nächste Marble Machine baut.
Und da sind so Passagen dabei, wo
er wahrscheinlich
seine Spiegelreflexkamera auf die
Marble Machine hält und daneben steht.
Und was erklärt, was da gerade zu sehen ist.
Der steht mal links und mal rechts von der
Kamera. Und der ist
dann halt ganz dolle im Stereo
nur auf einer Seite zu hören.
Und das ist schon unangenehm, wenn du
vor Lautsprechern stehst, weil es einfach
derartig weiter
Stereo-Unterschied ist, weil das
wirklich nur auf der einen Seite ist, dass du für einen Moment
denkst, ist mein Ohr auf der anderen
Seite gerade kaputt gegangen oder sowas?
Ich finde das aber total anstrengend,
wenn du sowas auf Kopfhörern hast, dass das halt
nur auf einer Seite zu hören ist.
Ja genau, jetzt gibt es hier auf dieser Seite noch weitere
Audiobeispiele.
Das klingt
alles so ein bisschen nach
Gameboy Musik.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass
du damit auch wahrscheinlich schön parametrisierte
Musik auf so ein Spiel legen könntest.
Bei jedem Track kannst du noch auf Open klicken,
und dann geht dann halt so ein wirkliches
CCFX-Interface an
und da siehst du jetzt wirklich
den gesamten Sequencer
und welche Töne da abgespielt haben.
Das ist ein herrliches Spielzeug, ehrlich gesagt.
Da kannst du jetzt Tracks bauen.
Klingt sehr cool.
Genau, also Leute, baut Musik damit.
Baut uns unser nächstes
Akronomisierer-Intro damit.
Oh, oh, das wäre der Hammer.
So, und jetzt du.
Okay, ich habe mir tatsächlich mal
C-Sharp oder liebevoll
von mir auch CIS genannt.
Software rausgesucht.
Quasi Musik von diesem Ufer.
Das ist ein
Server für Among Us, ein Spiel, das
aktuell sehr populär ist. Hat
sich tatsächlich jemand mal angeschaut,
wie er in der Zweckverkehr funktioniert
und einen Server reverse-ingeniert und
einen eigenen gebaut. Finde ich sehr cool.
Kannst den Server quasi selber hosten.
Heißt Imposter. Finde ich geil. Ich hätte es auch
Org oder der User, ich bin gar nicht, ob das User
oder nicht, der Org, die Org auch
Imposter heißt, also github.com.imposter
kannst du runterladen, den klein starten
und du musst halt dein eigentliches Spiel
ein bisschen patchen. Da gibt es irgendwo eine Datei, die du ändern musst,
wo der fragt, wo die Server
IPs sind und davon sich dann mit
denen redet. Und da musst du die
hier von deinem Localhost eintragen,
beziehungsweise wahrscheinlich das woanders hinlegen,
damit andere Leute mitspielen können.
Leider geht das natürlich auf, ich weiß gar nicht,
laut Wiki, glaube ich, muss man auf
iOS einen Jailbreak haben. Ich kann mir mal vorstellen,
vielleicht auch den Request,
wo der abfragt, wo die Servers stehen,
ob man den MITM kann und da was
reinschiebt, weiß ich nicht. Aber ich finde es sehr cool,
dass jemand quasi einen eigenen Server dafür geschrieben
hat. Das ist mega cool.
Cool.
Genau. Das war der eine Pick und der andere,
den ich noch mal auf die Liste gepackt habe, auch weil der gerade
im Akkumulisierbar-Matrix-Channel
letztens recht gut durchdiskutiert
wurde, ist AdGuardHome.
Ich habe es selber noch nicht aufgesetzt. Das ist quasi eine Alternative
zu Pi-Hole, aber nicht
im PHP-Geschäft, wie auch im
Chat mit das Thema war.
Passt aber sehr gut dazu, weil ich auch
auf meinen Gerichten überall AdGuard benutze als AdBlocker
und AdGuard Home
ist quasi DNS-based
network-wide
AdBlocking und Tracking
Blocking und das Schöne daran ist
es halt, dass du das quasi für
dein gesamtes Netzwerk nutzen kannst und da kannst du es
auf einem Always-On-Rechner
daheim, auf einem Pi, was auch immer installieren
und das quasi als dein
machen und dann Netzwerkweit auf
allen Geräten, sei es dein blöder Smart-TV,
sei es dein
Rechner, sei es dein Handy, sei es
deine Uhr, was auch immer, überall das
mitblocken. Also genau das selber, was Pyhole macht,
bloß ich finde es ein bisschen schicker und wie gesagt
sehr passend, weil ich auch Edgar und anderswo
nutze. Ich finde es sehr cool, dass sie das gemacht haben
als Self-Hostable,
Self-Hostable, doch,
Self-Hostable Teil.
Hast du das, du hast gerade gesagt,
du hast es auf einem Gerät bei dir im
Heimnetzwerk laufen.
Du kannst es theoretisch auch auf dem VPS installieren.
Das geht genauso.
Unterstützen die auch.
Der Nachteil daran ist halt,
ich habe einen ganz spezifischen Use Case,
dass ich genau ein Gerät...
Visual Private Server.
Also in der Cloud.
Oder wo auch immer.
Der Nachteil ist halt,
ich möchte in meinem Netzwerk sein,
weil ich Mac-Adressen filtern möchte.
Ich möchte genau ein Gerät eben nicht blocken.
Und das geht schlecht, wenn ich außerhalb des Netzwerks bin.
Ja, das stimmt.
Cool. Hast du das irgendwie auf deinem NAS?
Oder hast du das auf einem...
Ich wollte es auf einem Pi installieren. Ich habe es noch nicht installiert.
Ich habe es mir bloß vorgenommen, eigentlich am Wochenende jetzt mal zu machen.
Ich habe es nur mal testweise gestartet auf meinem Desktop-Rechner.
Läuft fantastisch. Die Konfiguration ist super easy.
Und du kannst es auch einfach mit Docker deployen.
Das macht es für mich sehr angenehm, weil ich da weiß, wie ich das Ding anfassen muss.
Ich überlege bloß gerade, wenn du so ein NAS hast,
auf dem kannst du auch noch weitere Docker-Container deployen.
Ich habe vor einer Weile mal versucht, Pi-Hole auf meinem Synology zu installieren
und habe da halt massive Networking-Issues,
dass ich nicht wirklich an das Ding rankam,
um das als DNS-Server anzusprechen.
Und deswegen will ich das gar nicht eigentlich für sowas benutzen.
Da habe ich Angst, dass das irgendwie sonst viel kaputt geht.
Und wenn es läuft, super.
Aber ich habe es nicht hinbekommen damals mit Pyhole
und werde deswegen mit dem hier auf den selben Gründen
die Finger von lassen.
Also da kann ich Software natürlich nichts dafür.
Das war wirklich Networking aus dem Synology,
was komisch war.
Und vielleicht habe ich mich absolut blöd angestellt.
Aber das möchte ich nicht mal ausprobieren.
Ich bin jetzt am überlegen, wenn ich mir das einrichten würde,
würde ich mir noch ein weiteres, würde ich mir zum Beispiel
ein extra Raspberry Pi
dafür holen.
Nur habe ich bereits bei mir irgendwie ein oder
zwei davon rumliegen, wo
zum Beispiel mein Home
Assistant drauf läuft,
mit dem ich meinen Lichtanwalt ausmache.
Das ist sicher nicht ausgelastet durch sowas,
also weder durch das eine noch solche Sachen.
Nee, aber du hast ja häufig bei solchen Sachen, hast du so eine
Appliance-Images, dass du sagst,
ach so, ah, okay, ja.
Der Pi macht dann wirklich nur dieses,
System. Und dann wird es ja irgendwann
schon interessant, dass du so eine Art,
dass du dir so ein Raspy
Rack hinstellst, wo du sagst, hier noch
ein Raspberry Pi mit noch einem weiteren
Appliance OS drauf, was dann einfach noch mit
anschließt, es kriegt dann Strom.
So Hot Swarm Pies, die du da so reinziehen kannst.
Gibt es das?
Ja, sowas gibt es.
Raspberry Pi
Rack. Das gibt es schon seit Anbeginn
des Raspies.
Natürlich erstmal irgendwelche Rezepte
für Fruit Smoothies.
Natürlich.
Das ist immer das Schöne an der Filterbubble, wenn man sie trainiert hat,
dazu die richtigen Sachen zu machen.
Meine Hoffnung ist ja, dass ich bei dieser Suchmaschine,
die ich hier verwende, keine Filterbubble habe.
Ja, eben. Aber ich meine, das ist ja der Vorteil
an der Filterbubble, wenn man halt trainiert hat,
auf sowas hin, dass du einfach nur
C googeln kannst und du findest nur Dinge zu C.
Ach, so ein Raspberry-Rack
ist schick. Das würde ich ja fast da haben.
Ja, nice. Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Cool. Also, das heißt,
wir bauen uns jetzt noch einen weiteren Raspberry hin
mit Edgard.
Das ist mein Plan fürs Wochenende.
Das mal aufzusetzen.
Wie gesagt, ich hab's mal ausprobiert auf dem Rechner direkt.
Läuft fantastisch. Eine super angenehme
Funktion. Da müsst ihr ja quasi nur die
DNS-Anfragen
drüber. Du musst ja nicht dein gesamtes Netzwerk da drüber
pipen. Genau. Du kannst aber auch direkt
deinem Router sagen, dass der da die
DNS-Anfragen hinmacht. Ach, siehste mal, genau das war
das, was ich beim letzten Mal, als wir drüber geredet haben,
dann tatsächlich gemacht habe, dass ich einfach,
es gibt eine Funktion in der Fritzbox,
wo du irgendwie solche Filterlisten in der Fristbox hinterlegen kannst.
Ja, aber nicht die Filterlisten,
sondern dass du quasi die Fristbox,
ihre DNS-Anfragen dahin lassen lässt.
Das wird ja auch was weitergefordert, oder?
Das stimmt natürlich auch, ja.
Also zumindest die Lösung...
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher.
Ich habe nicht so viel Ahnung, was DNS quasi,
wenn du das erstmalig einrichtest,
wenn du auf ein Gerät auspackst, ein neues,
wo macht denn das DNS-Anfragen hin?
Das fragt doch bestimmt bei deinem Router an,
was DNS-Server sind, oder?
Naja, das hängt immer
doll vom System ab.
Und von der Anwendung selber,
die ja auch ihren Stack drin hat.
Es kann sein, dass irgendwie DNS
von, ich glaube, Chrome oder
sowas hat es, glaube ich, oder Fairfax
haben es eingebacken, dass sie es einfach selber machen.
Oder es gibt auch eine API, wo du
bei Betriebssystemen abfragst, was ist denn hier
gerade der DNS-Server? Das ist eine gute
Frage, das merke ich gerade.
Da holen wir uns mal ein bisschen Feedback von
euch lieben Hörern.
Was mir eingefallen ist, dass die Filterliste auf der Fritzbox
einrichten hat irgendwie nicht funktioniert.
Okay.
Ich hätte es auch nur zwei Wochen lang benutzt.
Da waren zu viele
Post-Positives drin, die ich einzeln wieder rausfiltern musste.
Genau, das ist nicht schön. Und wenn du jetzt hier
so ein Ad-Card hast, dann gehst du einfach auf deine
Ad-Card.local oder irgend sowas
und dann
kannst du es einfach an oder ausmachen.
Das ist natürlich nicht schlecht.
Ja, auf jeden Fall.
Wie funktioniert das dann, wenn du
du hast es schon mal ausprobiert, wie funktioniert das dann,
wenn du ein bestimmtes Gerät rausnehmen möchtest?
Zum Beispiel, was weiß ich,
dass du dein,
du hast irgendwie so einen dummen Smarty,
mir fällt gerade kein gutes Beispiel, ein Gerät, was irgendwie
sich auf den Rücken legt, wenn es
plötzlich seine Werbung nicht mehr runterladen kann.
Bei uns, der Use Case explizit ist genau ein iPad,
auf dem YouTube Werbung angezeigt werden soll,
um die
Creator zu unterstützen. Und das ist halt,
ist ja nicht verkehrt, aber genau
deswegen soll da eben Werbung angezeigt werden.
Und das, also wie man das macht,
ist, du kannst in deinem Router einstellen,
dass das Gerät eine feste IP immer bekommt
im lokalen Netzwerk.
Und dann machst du es genau an der IP fest.
Ich hätte jetzt interessiert,
ob der Adguard sagen könnte,
zeig mir mal alle Geräte,
die du schon mal gesehen hast
und dann kann ich auswählen,
welches ich davon jetzt durchlasse.
Das geht vielleicht auch, weiß ich nicht.
Aber du kannst auf jeden Fall
verschiedene Filterregeln
aufgrund von Basis von verschiedenen Bedingungen anlegen.
Cool.
Das ist eine sehr angenehme UI, wie gesagt.
Ähnlich angelehnt an das, was bei NextDNS
zum Beispiel läuft. Das ist quasi aus dem Service in the Cloud.
NextDNS, die machen genau das.
Finde ich auch ganz witzig,
wenn man das nutzen möchte.
Nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht, nicht schlecht.
Na gut. Ja, also ich hab noch einen.
Ich hab noch einen. Ach so, stimmt.
Einen Pick hab ich noch. Und dann können wir
die Zuhörer auch in den nächsten Podcast
entlassen. Und zwar hab ich,
jetzt muss ich den Link finden.
Wo hab ich's denn hingetan?
Ach ja, hier.
Schlecht beschriftet, muss ich noch aufräumen.
Und zwar gibt es eine schöne
AI-Anwendung,
die
Lo-Fi
Hip-Hop produziert. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es Lo-Fi
Hip-Hop nennen würde, aber kennst du diese ganzen
Lo-Fi und
Chill-Pop-Playlisten
auf YouTube? Diese so irgendwie
Merkel-Räder auf 0,5
Prozent Geschwindigkeit? Nein, nein,
Chill-Pop einfach.
Das ist
ein ganzes Genre. Das ist glaube ich,
das war es in den
frühen 2000 und der Smooth Jazz
war, ist jetzt
Lo-Fi Hip-Hop.
Da musste man einfach nach Lo-Fi
oder Chill-Hop auf YouTube
besuchen. Dann hast du da meistens irgendwie so ein Anime-Mädchen,
was irgendwie bei Regenwetter zu Hause
sitzt und liest oder am Computer
sitzt oder so ein Waschbär am
Laptop oder sowas und dann läuft das.
Klingt irgendwie,
es klingt irgendwie,
da gibt es halt solche Streams, die dann irgendwie die ganze Zeit
irgendwie so Lo-Fi-Musik anhören kannst. Und Lo-Fi ist
auch ein ziemlich cooles Genre, ehrlich gesagt. Da gibt's
auch von dem Adam Neely
gibt's ein richtig abgefahrenes
Videos zum Thema Lo-Fi-Hip-Hop
und Lo-Fi-Jazz. Das ist aber was anderes.
Sorry, war ganz so, was ich
gerade meinte, packe ich mal einen Link in die Shownotes, das ist
betitelt als
Lo-Fi-Merkel-Wave.
Das ist ein Genre. Genau,
das Thema ist nämlich, das
Genre ist nämlich schon so prävalent,
dass es mittlerweile auch verarscht wird.
Das ist keine Verarsche, das
Video ist ein paar Stunden lang, habe ich
Nee, nur eine Stunde lang. Das habe ich mir jetzt dreimal gehört
auf Arbeit letztens.
Das hört sich auch ganz gut. Zumindest kann man das jetzt
auch live im Browser erzeugen lassen mit dem
Lo-Fi-Player, den ich hier in den Show Notes habe.
Und den kann ich,
den habe ich auch schon eine Weile nicht mehr angehabt.
Und da kannst du,
da hast du auch so eine Situation, wo einer zu Hause
sitzt, das ist so eine Pixel-Grafik und der guckt aus dem
Fenster und die Katze guckt auch aus dem Fenster und draußen
regnet es. Und da kannst du hier
auf unterschiedliche Sachen klicken, zum Beispiel auf den Bass
und dann kannst du den Bass an- oder ausmachen.
Und dann läuft einfach so eine Loop, die du so ein bisschen
irgendwie erzeugt ist und die du aber
ein bisschen modifizieren kannst. Das ist eigentlich ganz nice.
Das ist angenehm. Also
ein sehr angenehm zugehörbarer Noise-Generator.
Genau.
Ich wechsle jetzt hier von Piano zu
Acoustic-Guitar und
das ist...
Und dann, ja.
Wenn du auf den Typen klickst, dann nimmt er seine Tasse hoch.
Da kann man ein bisschen
drauf rumklicken. Das ist ein sehr schöner
Hacker-News-Find.
sehr appellastig und sehr musikalisch
die Folge heute auf jeden Fall
ja geil, dann zum ersten Mal wieder
seit zu lange
ich glaube es ist ja zwei Monaten, kann das sein
ich meine wir haben ja sonst
schon immer ein bisschen Mut zur Lücke gehabt
mit immer mal
einem Monat oder anderthalb Monaten Unterbrechung
aber das war jetzt schon ein bisschen
wenn wir schon auf Twitter gefragt werden
ob wir aufgehört haben
also seit drei Monaten
quasi, das ist fast ziemlich genau, morgen werden sie gesagt
drei Monate
Ei, ei, ei, ei.
Also wir haben im September oder Oktober gar keine Folge, aber egal.
Sag mal, was machen wir eigentlich dieses Jahr
zum Kongress, wenn es keinen Kongress gibt
für eine Sonderfolge? Es gibt ja Kongress,
aber halt dezentral.
Da müssen wir mal gucken, was das
Sendezentrum da macht, ob man da irgendwie
so eine... Vielleicht machen wir einfach
trotzdem eine Crossover-Folge, halt komplett remote.
Wäre auch witzig, finde ich cool.
Können wir mal gucken, wer sich dafür findet.
Ja, cool.
Das war jetzt akronomisierbar Folge
44.
Jo, es war ein Fest.
Vielen Dank, dass ihr uns daran erinnert habt, diese Folge
mal wieder aufzunehmen.
Hat Spaß gemacht. Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Genau. Und die nächste Folge
in eurem Podcatcher kommt in 3,
2,
1.